[Music]
welcome
everybody we are back the h3 podcast
episode 100
i gotta tell you i wasn't sure we'd make
it to a hundred
we had a bumpy road we had some ups we
had some downs we had some goofs we had
some laughs we had some booths
but here we are for better or worse
episode for better 100.
um here we are we soldiered on
first of all thank you to our sponsors
stamps.com meonde23me
23 enemy and dollar shave club now today
is also very coincidentally the last
episode of the year which
happened so perfectly i was going to lie
and say it was episode 100 today
just so we could hit that milestone but
i didn't need to lie it wasn't
episode 100. he actually was that was
that was in the cards we're just gonna
skip through 100
99 so we were going to skip the yeah
just be like i don't know what you guys
are talking about
but magically it's episode 100 we have
so much to look back
on so today what we're going to do and i
think it's going to be a lot of fun
is i'm going to bring ian and dan out
we're going to all sit here
and share our favorite and our
worst moments of the first 100 episodes
because
i think back to our first episode it was
pewdiepie oh yeah
sitting in his uh rental house in l.a
yeah and you if you look well we weren't
live streaming
for like the first 10 or 15 nine i
and we had like a really weird desk here
that one
and the guest would sit on this purple
couch it was very strange
but the big breakthrough i think came
for us when we started live streaming it
and when we got this table in
we started to feel the format more
and obviously i'm still developing a lot
um god please tough please god let there
be room to grow
what haven't you always said that the
rule is the first hundred you don't know
what you're doing until the first
hundred episodes
that's what that's what i say and and so
you're kind of a master now
please god let that be true
no there's it's there's been so much to
learn i heard someone say that you don't
know until the
2 50 episode yeah we gotta push that
out we gotta push that back because now
that we're at 100 the pressure's on
i heard joe rogan say you don't know
until a thousand
so i think we still have a lot of room
to go
um so we're gonna bring everyone out
we've got a ton of great things to look
back on i mean we've been doing this for
two years
it took us two years to get to 100
episodes there's a lot of
great moments that i forgot even
happened that we're gonna look over
um so i can't wait i'm super excited and
i've just
everyone who's tuned in and stuck around
for this wild ride i thank you
so much it's been a incredible journey
here and um looking forward to getting
to that but before we do
we had our huge charity stream on
tuesday
which we streamed for eight and a half
hours the longest day of my life still
recovering from that
that was absolutely brutal and against
all odds
we hit a hundred thousand dollars live
hey
i couldn't believe it i had to live
because i was sick i'm still kind of
sick
right but um i got home and you i think
you just reached the 75 and i thought
that's how you guys were going to leave
but justin was like no way you have to
stop until 100.
and then it happened pretty fast like i
couldn't believe it
um why is it not letting me sign into my
you need permission from ethan i'm
i am ethan signing off not letting me
log into this
stats um would this email
yeah i'll get you so at any rate we uh
well yeah because i could tell first of
all zach our sound guy had
a finals the next day everyone was they
got here before us
i was they were like here they were they
were here for like 15 hours that day
yeah and so everyone was getting tired
and i was like all right we can't
you know but but justin pushed us on
and it was so good that he did yeah we
hit it
okay here we go i got access so let's so
i want to go over some stats i'm i'm
very i'm always fascinated by
what reward item raised the most money
because it's always unexpected yes and
by the way
this is still up for another 10 days
yeah
so you can still bid you can still
donate
and help out a great cause link is in
the description
link is in the description so top donors
i gotta say we inched out alex for
a hundred bucks because of you ela
donating from home you donated 400 from
home
and we got there now there's so many
super generous people here
um i'm gonna out justin that was justin
i was very generous
of him alex was very generous james
wayne hoff donated two thousand one
hundred
will cheer up donated two thousand i
mean so many more
that channel yeah we had him he was
chilling in the background
yeah and then we're gonna take a call
who's calling in later today
uh fifths who's this uh just a few more
down on that list god bless him
so ran out of time on tuesday but we'll
speak to him later in the episode here's
the real interesting stuff
so of all the rewards here is what
raised the most money and again you can
bid on all this stuff okay
get the heck out of here this pivot
table so
most of all was nothing these generous
mf's everything oh really was 26
000 from the kindness of my heart
wow yeah pretty amazing and then alex
crushed it with that limited edition uh
the journal the journal raised 12
000. so this i love the nintendo switch
coming in a 300 investment we bought one
of every gaming system
a switch a ps4 and an xbox right
and together combined and that was a
last minute idea
of viewers right uh yeah that was
a good one so that 1200 bucks raised
20 000. that was the best freaking
return on best friend ever
but the switch raised 9 000 that's so
cool post guitar i'm happy to see you
raised 8
300. write something on ethan's fupa god
bless
rick and morty script um lots of
original art hugging it out oh i think i
put a thousand on that one god i hope i
get it
people are gonna think it's rigged if i
get it though right what do we do about
that
well that's it's random but then um
there's so many but really guys i want
to encourage everybody to keep donating
because if you go down to the bottom a
lot of the original
art that we drew towards the end they
didn't get that many donations
original alex hirsch artwork by justin
raylan eight bucks
if you go put eight bucks on that right
now you have a 50 chance
i'm gonna go put eight bucks on that uh
there's a ton of [ __ ] what other
original justin
roilan artwork by alex hirsch a hundred
bucks
signed rick and morty skateboard that's
all of our signatures a hundred bucks
original alex hirsch artwork pop mashup
a hundred bucks the shredder one where
was that one that one
shreddy naish original alex hirsch
artwork shredder niche vape niche
only 260. there's one of my drawings
there where it's still available
i mean they're all still around 300. no
under yeah there's another one lower
oh no original ela artwork featuring
justin alex 180.
so this [ __ ] is valuable i think really
valuable this is original art by three
freaking amazing artists
so if you want to help support the cause
please consider donating
and you have the chance to win some
beautiful wonderful original art and so
many other great prizes i encourage you
to go check that out this time the
prizes were crazy
the prizes were bananas frankly and also
the rick and morty comic
original comics signed where's that one
because that oh here it is
raised four thousand i think that
thing's worth honestly five thousand
so you already have a good chance of
winning that i think a good value for
your money
so there you have it there's a lot of
amazing prizes and i think everyone that
was a that was an amazing
ride wasn't it what are we at now dan
like 130 000 or something
yeah i think we just broke that uh right
before going live
cool and it continues to climb good and
also it's such a tough time for people
with
christmas yeah holiday gifting
so people are we're really generous and
that's very generous and i want to say
because i'm afraid i didn't emphasize it
enough during because we're so
focused on getting the gold i was like
please let me go home
no every dollar matters and to everyone
everyone who even dropped one dollar to
help
is just it makes a big difference it's
super generous
and it's very much appreciated it's a
beautiful thing and is tax deductible
i don't know how much a one dollar tax
deduction will get you but
you know hey mark it off like you said
every bit counts
you know do it again next as benjamin
button said a penny a dollar
deducted is a dollar earned
yeah benjamin franklin i believe was the
one who said that
i did a little remix alright well enough
of that
[ __ ] let's get on to our favorite
moments
of 2018. so i would like to welcome
the other half of the show with whom it
would not be possible and who
i want to say dan and you come in here
i'd like to say have truly
been a blessing to this show
i want to say that their presence has
made such a difference
and add so much uh presence
ian brings so much character to the show
with his power points
do we have a powerpoint today didn't we
supposed to do that you're
fired i take everything um
no ian and dan
please join us we couldn't do we
couldn't do a year-end recap without
these two guys
um so what's going on
but yeah what happened with that kanye
decoding
we were so slammed this week and with
the
teddy fresh stuff too it was like i
didn't have enough time
well ian has been doing all of our
customer support emails
by the way if you ever complain you're
talking to ian you're not talking to a
a robot nope that's either that's
literally
a celebrity is answering your question
yeah so if you hit me with uh you know
[ __ ] you that's
right here it feels this week you got
the first [ __ ] you once
oh you did yeah oh tell me about it i
didn't hear about that oh yeah you
weren't here
tell me everything well yeah i mean
you know people you know it's holidays
it's a little heated
very time sensitive how did you take it
did you take a personal thank you
well i exploded on him flipped out no
listen buddy yeah no it happens you
don't know me
well it's there's been a lot of delays
and uh
unfortunately there's a lot of packages
getting delayed
well just remember it's ian's fault
but the truth is we're trying to get you
out of the the trenches there because
uh you're creative you're a brilliant
guy and i need that
big beautiful brain comedy brain of
yours uh working in my benefit
thank you decoding stuff yeah i need you
i need to squeeze that
for the valuable juice that it is worth
all right and dan
has been with us longer than anyone yeah
i guess so
yeah um it's crazy how times passed
but here we are um and we let's talk
about our favorite moments now
how should we do this i've got a bunch
of mine maybe i'll i'll go
do do you think they should present
first because i have a [ __ ] ton you guys
have less than me
no well you have like the general stuff
yeah stuff that came from fans yeah
right yeah i've got i've got it all
let's do those first and then the
personality so this
is everything from the first 100
episodes now
joey salads from the last charity stream
this will always go down as one of my
favorite
moments in asia podcast history now the
back story of this is that
um because at the time we weren't really
equipped to
live stream so joey salads live streamed
it from his phone on his personal twitch
channel
and it went across the street from the
office and we watched it on the tv
yeah we watched it with a delay but we
had them on the phone
yeah so we were hearing the audio
through the phone and then watching his
stream which made it better because
we we heard the screaming about 15-20
seconds before
the impact and i love how just so
casually
and calmly justin has accepted the
burden of
pepper spraying joey salad he loves it
he had no hesitation
at all yeah yeah justin
this was a legendary moment and um and
funnily
joey salads was banned from twitch
for doing a dangerous act but but our
channel
were fine oh poor guy i think he was
re-uh
sorry joey without further ado
no [ __ ] crap
oh my god who was recording was that you
yeah that was me
what was it like being there seeing that
this was like
i'd only been here a couple weeks at the
time
and i remember i called my mom after i
was like a guy just got pepper sprayed
where are you working were you afraid
that it will reach you
too no you didn't feel it i kept the
distance
and so to this day joey says that was
infinitely worse than uh
you guys kept it real professional ian's
following the action
good camera yeah yeah it's kind of like
when you're filming
like a wildlife shot and like a like a
gator is attacking a deer and you can't
intervene and save the dude
no you have to just watch the pain and
that nature play out yeah they call that
in star trek the rules of uh
well that's the non-intervention it's
the the first protocol
the first the reference the first
direction directive there you go
ian had a prime directive and you upheld
it valiantly i wonder how could we top
it next year because the
well we're gonna have to throw them off
the building
we kind of yeah that's sort of an issue
because um
we we went for broke on that first one
yeah and then
because joey got uh got banned as a
result
we're a little reluctant to go that far
again well i don't know if that might
happen but
i wanted to shoot him with a non-lethal
beanbag right but i was like that's not
that's not gonna fly yeah so we have to
the thing about the spicy pepper is that
even though it's very painful it's not
necessarily dangerous
so youtube doesn't see it as like a
banneable offense
so if we can get a professional stuntman
and like a safety crew
we may be able to throw them off a
building
maybe next time we can get some
submissions because yeah get some ideas
we have
creative people listening and next up
boogie now boogie is such an incredible
guest because
he always he doesn't hold back
um yeah and he has a he had a story in
his
last visit about dating a feeder yeah i
knew that it was gonna happen
such a pleasure such a pleasure and so
here we go she oh she's like come in and
uh i'm so sorry to say this is she's
laid them across her chest down her
stomach to make an arrow
to her vagina and then she had filled
her vagina
with maraschino cherries
for dessert i swear to god
and my first thought is you are going to
get a yeast infection what the [ __ ] are
you
doing like don't put food in your vagina
how many of you stuff in there six or
seven i was like you know but i was
like one of the best experiences
[Laughter]
[Music]
i got sick i got like an infection in my
leg i don't know which is like real
frequent i get in with the lymphedema
all the time
and i'm like i gotta go to the hospital
she's like they're gonna make you lose
weight
and i'm like no no no that's gonna be
fine i've gone i've gone before the
storm
crazy yeah jesus i'm like mom turned
dark
really dark yeah [ __ ] you okay we're
done
like i'm not gonna die like literally
she's like you're faking the infection
how do you fake an infection what are
you [ __ ]
talking about this [ __ ] was
you know what ultimately is the goal of
feeding someone the
that leads to death that's the one path
but what wasn't mentioned in this
highlight is that he did eat the
cherries out of her
of her vagina what a guy what a legend
yeah i love that
i like the on the highlight there's a
comment from some guy
saying lady if you're watching this
video i'm 300 pounds
put on weight i don't know if 300 pounds
qualifies yet
because boogie said he was at like 500
people yeah that's right but i guess
he's got lots of ways to go if a fur
feeder is a lot it's a long road to go
together
um oh this now this one i completely
forgot this was submitted by a fan
and this is when we had tai lopez on the
podcast and we got him good
because we had this video where we went
to his house and
he had a lawyer a troop of lawyers
following me the whole time
and so we decided to get him back good
when he came on our own podcast and we
hired an
extra that you found on craigslist right
dan
uh yeah well i mean actually yeah i got
off craigslist
but we all forgot that we did that yeah
that's when we saw the submission
right same how you how did you find them
how did you what did you mark i put up
just
need an actor for one day for like an
hour i got a lot of weird people
yeah so that was a little but kind of
combed through it and then he was
very game we like put him in the closet
yeah right
right because he couldn't really cool
too like because you never know what
you're going to get with craigslist
especially actors
are already all weird and craigslist
actors
bottom but you hit the jackpot with that
guy because he got it he got what the
gag was and he played it completely
straight it was amazing
he sat in our tiny little closet room
for like out an hour at least just
because we're like just being in there
like if you need to use the bathroom go
do it quick because you can't come back
he was so game too it was totally cool
what did we pay him do you remember
i don't i don't remember probably
probably more than girls get for kissing
prank
uh yes yeah almost certainly yes it was
a couple hundred i mean it was an easy
day for him
obviously it worked like a couple hours
after he had a couple hours
i remember afterwards then he was like i
know that guy
he recognized oh for real yeah i
remember that
i've seen his ass all over youtube yeah
exactly so here it is this is
i watched this this morning i was like
oh my god this is brilliant
and he plays it he's so straight too
like you say
wow he gets that's not noticeably fluffy
they're outside i love that shot how we
set the camera
look at ty i took i took a picture out
the window
one hour or two hours before right of
that
that festival this is that was insane i
left that way was he completely ignoring
what was happening yeah
crazy like you can see he wants to look
over the world like existing
and he keeps imposing on him yeah
you uh you i couldn't help but
vegas i was in vegas i was speaking at a
conference whoa
to entrepreneurs wanting to scale their
business
can you just can you just bring a little
bit closer i just want you to miss
anything
don't worry about it did you bring your
lawyer
okay no don't worry about he's not he's
like an intern
he's going to read me my miranda rights
i like this
this is good he's doing the camera it
turns out great don't worry just try not
to think about it
[Laughter]
oh my god he's scaring me all right
all right you're starting to scare me
now so thanks for your service to us
very well done by the way lots of
intimidation is going to serve me by the
way
now another favorite is that our first
prank ever
that's like kind of a prank that was a
really early episode
i want to say tai was like 16. 16 17. it
was pretty early yeah
really it was it doesn't feel that long
ago now that i see it but
tai lopez it was a year ago yeah let's
see if this one
or uh number thirty three
a little higher um october 4th
so it was over a year ago over a year
what is this cold open the new episode
of the h3
what is this look at this [ __ ] when have
we ever started oh i think this
podcast starring your boy oh because of
the game i remember when he had
attorneys oh that's why explained it
yeah
that's cute was this live
it might have pre-recorded yeah it was
pre-recorded yeah
um vsauce michael here
one of my all-time favorite guests
another the guy is
open book he's hilarious we talked to
him about
uh taking ayahuasca which is a
psychedelic drug
yes it is and i thought it was a
wonderful conversation by the way
oh i just realized if dan is here he
tells us about
break time oh who's telling us about
oh is it breakdown i've been keeping an
eye on the clock okay
so 3 45 will be 30 minutes all right we
started late okay um
vsauce is coming back our first episode
back yeah
25th of january we'll we'll be joined by
vsauce again
so i'm very much looking forward to that
but here he talks about taking
a psychedelic drug um which is just
the the combination of him
psychedelics and youtuber ed is just i
love that
those three things together is not
something you would expect
but he had a lot of interesting things
to say but here's the thing my heart was
going it was literally beating very fast
i actually there's a moment where i
touch my chest and i'm like yep it's
really happening
but then i thought how do i let the
doctor know
because i can't think no this is not how
i normally feel
is it weird if i just say hey um
help right how are they going to
interpret that and so
i just i thought maybe i'll just ask for
water
you know maybe that like will tether me
back down to reality because someone
will have to bring
me water and that's a really money this
is something i've been like i feel like
i've been in that headspace i'm trying
to like
i don't want to see me talk
[Laughter]
but um that was great love vsauce i love
him talking about that too because he is
so
analytical about his experience which
you know
it most people who do that are looking
for some sort of like spiritual
connection and he was more just trying
to like appreciate
what was happening to him the entire
time it was really cool to hear him talk
about
it yeah i would i would i would like to
just put michael
in a room and just give him all kinds of
drugs and just oh yeah record him let's
get that set up for the 25th i mean the
new
okay michael here's a mdma i believe you
know
um tell us how you feel the new season
is out i'm very much looking forward to
oh nice yeah we're going to talk all
about that on the 25th
now now garth brooks is somewhat of a
phenomenon here
and on other podcasts as well because
he's just such a legend
and there's one video specifically of
garf's that i love
where he goes uh he's sitting in his
hotel room
why don't i why don't we just watch it
because i don't think i can't watch this
too many times garth brooks
facebook right right um
i can't watch this video too many times
it's truly a masterpiece
well i guess it's official we're now on
facebook
i really wasn't sure about this at the
start but then a friend of mine said
something that just made all kinds of
sense
she said think of it more as a
conversation
i like that but i'm already finding out
on my own
so it's wiping the walls out between you
and me and i really like that
it allows us into each other's world
look at the
title garth brooks first facebook post
and video amazing
authentic and transparent 100 that's
funny because when i watch this i see
like the opposite
it's in my case a hotel room hotel room
this reminds me of tai lopez in in my
garage video in that oh yeah
it tries to look authentic and natural
but you know he's done it a thousand
least it looks like it's the same
quality the type of video you'd make
from the bunker after the bombs have
fallen
i really like that i like that you know
what would be fun
is to just maybe do like a gofundme and
then
run this as a youtube pre-roll
go find me yeah for people to donate and
then you use all that money
as a as a community and you use this as
a youtube pre-roll so people just get
this video oh a go fund me to pay to
have this as
youtube so it's just constantly popping
up that's that's kind of funny
i mean it's like kai lopez but he's not
selling anything but himself
i wonder if you get pissed or if you'd
love that uh everything i really like
that
people would be like what the [ __ ] i
mean that'd be amazing let's try to go
fund me
think about things i want to post i want
to post cool stuff
slick stuff neat stuff but most stuff
i'm going to post is going to be raw
stuff like this
because that is just who i am golly
so if this is truly a conversation then
i say let the conversation begin
and iconically after saying let the
conversation begin it was
the last video he ever posted i'd say
let the conversation
end yeah incredible good stuff
i've never seen that until you showed it
to me and now i find myself doing that
like that i like i like it i can't help
it and do people think you're being
strange because they don't oh
without a doubt that happens to me a lot
yeah we used to watch it so many times
but we didn't know what to do with it
like yeah i know but but as well
it was somewhat underground but i think
a lot of people are picking up on it now
but the great moment one of my favorite
moments is we had chris dalia
on and i saw that he was a garth brooks
um fan in the similar sense that i was
right
and i says to him i pitched him this
idea you i go you know what i want to do
i want to recreate this video word for
word and just post it and he's like
i think i've done that that's right so
here and we discover that he did it and
he didn't even remember i want to
recreate it
i want to upload this to my youtube
channel unedited i think
i think i did this and i uploaded it
you did it you recreated it i know i
really
i know i sent the video to
joe i know i sent it to joe right let's
see what happens and i think
the brian cowan i don't know if i ever
uploaded it
[Laughter]
it's not even that long ago oh yeah so
somebody found well i wonder
i really wasn't sure about this at the
start oh so friend of mine
it's back to back and i will say this
apologies like
i i didn't write it down
i watched it so many times
this is from i remember i remember it's
a straight feeling an authenticity yeah
i really like that it has fifty thousand
pretty views this is pretty insane that
this exists
like you brought up you thought you'd
bring it up but i'm like bro i'm waiting
i recreate this oh my look in the
[ __ ] i'm in my bedroom
you're in a hotel room right right yeah
come on i'm immersed
well i guess it's official we're on
facebook
you know i really wasn't sure about this
but a friend of mine said something that
made
all kinds of sense and she said just
think of it as a conversation
i like that you know what i'm already
noticing myself
is that it's wiping away the walls of
communication between you and me
okay well i really like that
yeah everybody can see this yeah [ __ ]
each other's worlds or in my case my
hotel room
[Laughter]
when i think about the things i want to
post cool stuff
slick stuff neat stuff but i'm probably
going to end up posting raw stuff like
this
because it's who i am
well i guess if this is a conversation
then i say
let the conversation begin
sound good i love it stumbled upon that
like accidentally it's just a joy and as
evil said it's now from 700
to 50 000 so don't anyone ever say that
we here at the h3 podcast didn't make a
difference
bringing joy to the world on some guy's
channel it's not even chris julia
and it is break time now oh it is break
time
so we have a lot more up next we've got
post malone patrice wilson
live spook that was not a joke
we've got so much so much more and then
my worst moments coming up and then your
guys's best and worst moments coming up
including hilo
do not go away guys this is episode 100
we are just getting started and i say
let the conversation begin
we'll be right back these days you can
get practically everything on demand
but why can't you get stamps did you
know that you can get postage on demand
all you need is stamps.com with
stamps.com you can access all the
services of the post office
right from your desk you can buy and
print real us postage of any letter or
any package all available 24 hours a day
seven days a week you just click
print mail and boom bada bing bob's your
uncle you're done
stamps.com will even send you a digital
scale
so that you can weigh it and then
properly print out the postage for it
you literally do not have to go wait in
lines at the post office anymore with
stamps.com
you're fully equipped you've got the
scale you've got the means
do it from home for christ's sake we do
everything else from home why not ship
now we've got we just did this charity
uh live stream
we've got a ton of stuff to ship guess
how we're doing it baby
stamps.com that's right because there's
no easier way that's the that's the
situation
right now we've even got a special offer
okay for h3 listeners
four-week free trial includes postage
and
a digital scale so don't wait go to
stamps.com
and before you do anything else click on
the radio microphone at the top of the
home page
and type in h3 for that special offer
that's stamps.com
go to the microphone and enter h3
are you crunching for christmas trying
to find that perfect gift
well no worries because everything you
need for you and your loved ones is over
at
meundies that's right mandy's uses the
coveted micro modal fabric which is
three times softer than cotton
and you've never felt fabric this soft
so get ready to experience the pure
bliss and underwear form now a lot of us
walk around
wearing normal cotton underwear and you
don't understand how important it is for
this beautifully soft micro model to rub
up against your precious jewels it will
change your life you will do not
understand how soft
and luxurious this is look at elo there
showing these beautiful luscious red
undies off
you can also get styles of perfectly
suited for your special someone men
women can choose from four different
cuts all of which are available from
classic colors to adventurous prints i'm
talking
jack-o'-lanterns holiday plaid and of
course my personal favorite
milk and cereal seriously
these fun undies would be a great
stocking stuffer but why stop at undies
mandy's has cozy lounge pants and
onesies and that's super
same soft fabric perfect for wearing on
christmas morning
meundies has got a great offer for my
listeners for any first time purchase
when you purchase any me undies you get
15 percent off
and free shipping that's right crunch
for time you can't go wrong with the
mandy's gift card so it's a no-brainer
you get 15
off the most comfortable underwear that
will ever rub up against your genitals
you may cream your pants but only the
first couple of times
so you'll get used to it it's that
comfortable to get 50 off your first
pair free shipping and 100
satisfaction guaranteed go to
meundies.com
h3 that's meundies.com h3
now through december 25th 23andme dna
kits are on sale
23andme helps you understand what your
dna can tell you about you and your
family's story it's named for the 23
pairs of chromosomes that make up our
dna
now when you take this you get 90 plus
personalized genetic reports that offer
dna insights to what makes you unique
and it's so easy to do
all you do is spit in a tube provided by
23andme kit which is the sexiest thing
i've done all year
register your sample to your personal
23andme account in a few weeks bob's
your uncle
you receive your personalized online
report here's some
things that it can tell you about
yourself just from uh analyzing a little
spit
mosquito bites how prone are you to get
bitten by mosquitoes
do you like the taste of cilantro some
people say cilantro tastes like
dishwasher soap i thought they were
insane but it turns out it's all genetic
musical pitch can you tell musical pitch
can you recognize
that's interesting wellness muscle
composition do you have the muscles
of a power elite power athlete
damn i did have that uh genetic
variant and so please address me as sir
in the future
and sleep movement do your arms and legs
switch while you're sleeping
well they've got a sleep movement report
you can discover how your genetics may
influence how much your arms and legs
move during sleep and so
so so so much more it's a fascinating
look into your genetic makeup
it's so unique and so interesting it's
so fun now through december 25th you get
30
off any 23andme kit order your dna kit
at 23andme.com
h3 that's the number 23andme.com
h3 again that's 23 and me dot com slash
h3 you get 30 off through december 25th
give it a shot i
love that dollar shave club has
everything i need to look feel and smell
my very best what i love even more is
the fact that i never have to go to the
store
that's because one dollar shape club
delivers everything i need right to my
door and two
they keep me fully stocked on what i use
so i never run out
here's how it works bye dollar shave
club has everything you need to get
ready no matter what you're getting
ready for
they have you covered head to toe for
your hair your skin
your face even your butthole you name it
they've got it
and they've got this new program where
they automatically keep you stocked up
on the products you use
you term you determine what you want and
when you want it and it shows up right
to your door
from once a month to every six months
that's what i do
i keep them coming every month and i
never run out especially those one wipe
charlies let me tell you as far as butt
wipes go it leaves a nice tingle on my
anus i'm telling you
there's a tingle and i love that about
it but the shampoo is
delicious it smells great she's all over
me
but i think it's because of my clean
butthole i could be wrong though um
plus what is that right elo it's the
clean butthole but plus with their
handsome discount the more you buy the
more you
save and right now they got a bunch of
starter sets that you can try for
just five dollars like their shower
starter set which includes the shampoo
after that the restock box ships regular
sized products at regular price
so what the f are you waiting for get
your starter kits for just five dollars
give them a shot
see if you like it see if it's right for
you i have a feeling you're gonna love
these products
so head on over to dollarshaveclub.com
h3
give him a shot try it for just five
bucks that's dollarshaveclub.com
h3 and we're back
thanks for sticking around everybody we
are here to
celebrate the 100th episode of the h3
podcast and look fondly back
um where was i post malone
never heard of always a favorite always
a treasure to have him on
but during was it his last appearance i
think so um there was the live show
after that
wow so yes um during one of his
appearances here
patrice wilson started live streaming
some really creepy stuff that seemed to
be directed towards me
and we were watching this unfold live
and it was very spooky
so he started broadcasting just a shower
curtain right in h3h3 was in the title
exactly and so
well look for yourself
yeah oh god i'm scared what is that
creepy
[ __ ] scream dude i have chills right
now we didn't know that it was scary
it's so creepy it's like a cd screen
like a screen with like
guck in it he was just moving behind it
no it's not a screen
[Laughter]
[Music]
is very spookable too yeah right so we
were all getting
we were all getting the creeps yeah um
patrice wilson is already a guy that's
just a little
strange right that's fair i think that's
the fair way to put it i just thought
it really scared the [ __ ] out of me when
i saw this
and it and it continues so so this
happened early on in the episode
and we closed it we're like all right we
can't have this is way too scary
and later on the live chat was saying
he's back
and it's changed and this part
really scared the [ __ ] out of me here
you have it
he's got a countdown timer that's a
cemetery a graveyard
just put trees in a cemetery that looks
so ridiculously
creepy i love you
is that goodbye goodbye
i'll spend the night with you well i'm
worried about december 1st that's what
i'm saying on december 1st yeah that's
when the night
let's do a getaway i don't want to be in
l.a why because he's here
[ __ ] that well just let him just hole up
with some shotties
you're [ __ ] i
there's not it's very vulnerable and it
makes me very vulnerable and you can
attack from
anywhere you know that's our only way to
kill me made everything way worse
now i've got a defensible high ground
when the time clock
ended we we left the house we didn't
want to be in the house just in case
yeah weren't you hiding in a grocery
store parking so
when the time when the clock went down
to zero
it was getting more provocative and more
threatening i felt
and i felt so unsafe in our last house
as well
that i was like and we just had got did
we have shredder at the time
i think we didn't i was really scared
for shredding cargo yeah and so we
we packed up we got shredder we went in
the car and we just drove into a public
parking lot and just held up for a
couple hours
because i was like look i don't [ __ ]
know what this guy's up to at all no
i would have done at least that i just
skipped town for the day
but then patrice was like why did
everyone think this was creepy
i was never rolling through a cemetery
yeah
well and there was even more he'd
directly address you at some point
he was like yeah no i know
i know oh my god um that was a wild one
yeah but it was special i we shared it
with post
live and it was a special beautiful
moment
it's just one of many um jordan peterson
hits the vape god
now there's an internal debate in this
office
because we have retired the vape god and
i think
for guests like jordan peterson it is so
fantastic
to have them hit it but ila holds the
opinion and she's not necessarily wrong
that it's really disgusting and weird
requesting
but you know and i i appreciate that she
thinks it's dirty but we keep it clean
don't we dan oh yeah sure what
you clean the food yeah yeah yeah i mean
there i don't know yeah and there's not
much yeah i mean we wipe off the tube
and sterilize it before somebody new
hits it or whatever but um
i to me it's more so that it's like
right off the bat
some people might feel obligated to do
it when they really don't want to
and then that starts the interview on a
weird foot well and but we're i mean
as i guess we're about to see jordan the
person i thought would be like hell no
and yeah he was well that's super down
that's the problem right is that
you on one hand say this is a little
strange and they're gonna be
uncomfortable
but then on the other hand you have
moments like this
okay so i'm i'm happy to comply rip it
fast
okay so i just breathe in breathe in i
got the bun
fat rips nice he's like staring at you
this is
[ __ ] legendary damn you know
[Music]
they know how to do this up there that
was impressive i remember he said
um rituals are important
yeah that's funny was he the first one
we may do that
no we had harley and bobby lee and
everybody doing right
we had a lot of people doing it yeah
yeah um i feel like he was the first i
was he i know was thinking that too
because it yeah
doesn't it taste like battery acid or it
does some days
[Laughter]
gotcha piping that it goes through
uh definitely it it makes it taste a
little funky but it's already
if it did he was unfazed i think back
then it was
it was still a clean hit but as time has
gone on
it's so harsh that you feel like
better i mean it's a prop is the thing
like it was it was
made as a prop and so you know it's not
necessarily over the long term so so
what you're saying dan is that we need
to build a more
a more resilient little resident not a
prop essentially
yeah if you if you own a vape company
out there
hit us up podcast h3h3productions.com
well that was a special moment
regardless of if it was right or wrong
justin pranks joel austin another great
moment from last year's charity event
we called joel austin is this mega
preacher
who was in the media at the time because
he clo they had this horrible hurricane
hurricane and tons of people were
homeless and
without shelter and joel a man of god
had this mega church
in the worst area on the high ground
completely unaffected by the flooding
and the church was closed he wasn't
letting anybody in there yeah
so he was getting slammed all throughout
the media and we took it upon ourselves
to vigilante justice and justin
calls in joel osteen and the woman who
answers is just
i mean lack of a better term a little
bit of a looney tune
i think that's more than fair yeah so
here we go
keep saying ricky do you know someone
named
what does any of this mean i'm confused
is it
if i were to translate this would it be
uh
would it be like hey don't let people
into the building
during the flood because we don't want
a lot of jesus carpets
the blood of jesus jesus i heard you the
first time
[Music]
2015 was a good year
flight news flight news battles is that
a magazine you're eating
what are you talking about i am so
confused right now
this is supposed to be some kind of
yes oh it's a pair line
is it a prayer line where you just
ramble crazy nonsense
what language is this i just i'm gonna
call my translator so
i can follow the conversation
you're laughing at it because you know
it's funny because it's ridiculous
that's why you're laughing right now i
just made you
i think somebody filled us in that like
she's laughing at the demons
laughing at satan this is a thing
apparently
yeah black guy yeah it's part of the the
ritual to uh
to purge the evil out of her phone call
look dude that
was so crazy like that was so much more
insane
than ever could have never expected you
have to yes yeah he seems kind of
i may get some out of that do we still
have that number you want to call it
i think i could use it hit him up a
couple ricky ticky
people take [ __ ] too far this is what
this is christianity on
this is what happens when you overdose
on christianity
the blood of jesus oh my god
everything in
[Music]
you're moderation oh she's transferring
she's going to put me up to the next
level of prayer life
[Laughter]
she's like what did she do with you i'm
putting i'm putting she's like she
starts speaking in tongues and laughing
the demons
is a beautiful moment i remember that
made like not national news but like
there were like articles
right we had a viral moment right
yeah also the previous one made it into
articles with uh
post malone because he was saying he was
talking about when the stream was gonna
end december first he joked he joked and
then people oh no he said that was the
day
beer bong's embellishment yeah it's
gonna drop and everybody refers it was
like billboard was like
yeah and then people thought that was
the date of the release yeah
he's just goofing around and then
actually on december 1st i felt bad
yeah because he had to tweet out sorry
everybody album's not coming out today
it was he was so obviously joking what
the hell
people oh yeah that was great i mean
huge like rolling stones billboard
post malone reveals and when i saw those
articles i was like wait where did he
say that
and then to find that it was our stream
i'm talking about patrice
funny because they don't mention the
show they're just like post malone
said yeah yeah bastards they had
mentioned the show people would have
been like oh
it's not serious right now this was a
moment that i personally loved
is that the night before the jack black
episode
aired justin roiland reached out to me
and he said do you know that i used to i
met jack black long ago and he helped
me pitch and sell my first show ever and
he's a huge inspiration to me and was a
huge help to me
and he sent me all this incredible media
like pictures that said what did it say
keep um doors down
knock doors down and he had even done a
cameo in his first show that he sold
and jack was talking about how like um
bob odenkirk bob odenkirk and david
cross
had given them their big break by
putting them on mr show
and so that kind of gave me the perfect
end to be like wow
somebody you you've apparently uh you
know passed it on
and this was a beautiful moment
understand it from a mutual friend of
ours you are also an advocate
i have so i have a somewhat of a
surprise oh my god is am i going to be
surprised by someone from a blast from
my past going to enter the room
i think so oh no i'm really excited a
friend of mine
i reached out because i heard you're
going to say so cool
and i don't know that you've seen this
he said but i think that you i want to
say for the record i think that's one of
my favorite episodes we've ever done
yeah i know it's recent but honestly
like two of the best guests we've ever
had just so cool
so funny they hung out before and after
they sang for us after that was
incredible yeah we probably never
finished
the thing with zach this is so zach
who's our sound lad he's a musician he
shreds on guitar
well thank you very much and he um
kyle gas is like a crazy shredder and so
zach
and kyle and jack started jamming and
singing yeah uh
zach knew uh master exploder which is a
tenacious d
song and uh i think he was asking kyle
about his guitar
he was like here take a look or whatever
and he just started busting out into the
song
and like i had like the split second
moment of like oh like
you know don't try and like show them up
or whatever
i was completely wrong they immediately
just launch into the song and they like
play the entire song with him sing the
whole thing it was so cool how was that
for you zach
it was one of the highlights of my life
i do have a video of it um on my phone
but
i said i'll schlep to get that up maybe
we can tweet it later or something tweet
it later from the podcast
twitter that'd be great it was insane it
was just
like he started singing and that was
just like oh my god i can't believe this
is happening right now so
i could tell on zack's face he was
living out of fantasy
yeah they that's this really i mean
those guys and jack black is such a
legend like
man i used to be obsessed with his hbo
series it's one of the funniest things
ever seriously yeah it really when we
were researching for them coming in
um as part of it i went back and just
like watched some of it it's been years
i haven't seen it in forever
completely holds up so funny so good
like does it hold up yeah
yeah i find this joke
fairly tasteless you remember the butt
babies in the desert where kyle gives
a anal birth oh my god i love that
so good but at any rate where were we
be joyed by it wow you'll be joined by
you will be joined by
here we go tell me if you recognize this
oh my god it's justin roland yeah
oh my god so speaking of genius so
justin roilan jack black
helped justin royland pitch and sell his
first show
as ep wow jack helped justin get his
foot in the door
nope
and he believed in me and i just want to
say hi and thank you
and that he loves it what a mensch well
let me because you did it for me to be
able to convey that
sincerity to jack black come on
definitely and the fact that justin had
the pictures still
as good as it gets those polaroids i
guess let me find that for good thing
that he doesn't throw away anything i
know
i know and jack actually i i never
conveyed what justin said because i
showed him that clip
and he cracked up laughing when jack was
like oh justin's a saver
because justin is a hoarder when you go
in his house you can tell this guy
doesn't throw anything out ever
there it is there it is modest but he's
this is what he told me okay
look at i couldn't you know he sent me
this photo last night
blow doors down wow
[Laughter]
he's a different person he's a sweet kid
dude look at him yeah
that's wild i know look at that little
genius just wait
really a true genius oh justin
oh god he's like
he's like one of these crazy geniuses
that are like fearless
and like unhesitant you know like he
doesn't have a filter in the best way
possible
and he just he embraces this like his
game coming out is so imaginative
yeah and it's just it's like so uniquely
him you know it's almost
no one else could have made it but him
yeah he really is such a creative force
and uh truly an honor to consider him a
friend
and this was just really one of my
favorite moments probably
so there you have it
next what do we got thank you martin
here's a great one i'm almost done with
my list by the way
martin scarely admits to doing crimes
live
this i couldn't believe i forgot about
this one
like this this is legendary this was
another one of those unplanned
beautiful genius moments where we're
having a live show
with i think it was eric and jesse
wellins and
somebody and this was right after
schorrelli got like
uh sentenced or convicted the day was
convicted it was before the
sentencing which is is key to
why this was so amazing because right he
was
very much underplaying how much
punishment was coming his way well he
didn't know
and he well he seemed pretty confident
when he was saying he seemed to be
of the feeling that he was getting off
with the slap on the wrist
and he he asked us well how much he's
like i'm not admitting anything but
how how much jail time would you do for
a hundred million dollars
but also and we're like what do you mean
by that how did it happen we were just
talking about him
and then he and he was streaming and
then he started watching our stream on
his stream
yeah i think you know in the back i just
was keeping an eye on the chat
and people were just started spamming in
the chat hey uh
martin shkreli is like streaming right
now and he's watching you guys
like what the [ __ ] sure enough so we're
like well we
got we've got to get shkreli on here if
we can
and after you know trying to line it up
we finally figured it out and got him on
and and well here let me play the clip
for you because this
truly he's in prison right now as we
speak
and i've always suspected that
this clip of him on our show was played
before the judge when before sensitive
thinking
he goes listen to this i mean listen to
this yeah i just wanted
how much let me ask you guys a crazy
question if
you could make 100 million dollars but
you had to go to jail
how much time would you do is this
related to your situation
that's totally totally unrelated because
you just said you made thirty thousand
dollars and i feel like your answer was
sarcastic
yeah it seems to be a little bit of
intent now here yeah
this hypothetical situation seems to
have intent how much time would you do
i i mean um for how much 100 million 100
million
if i could wait what is the question i
want to do a year you [ __ ] tony
for 100 million dollars how much time
would you do he asked
just money how much time would i do yeah
am i like you're the orange is the new
block
is it on the expense of people yeah who
suffers
hey serve a year here's a bunch of money
nobody suffers
what would you do a year what would you
do what would you do zero to zero to 30.
i would do zero to 30 days
cause i asked your friend like
especially
i said so even if you assume i'm guilty
which i'm not i'm coming out of this
with
over a hundred million dollars and he
lost
money the judge took all like pretty
much all of his money right i don't know
including his routine
yeah so he lost everything yeah honestly
why even go on at that point but he's
such a cocky [ __ ] she couldn't help but
brag
right and it he couldn't come help but
come on and be like
if you could make a hundred million
dollars how much time would you do
it kept it kept going on on his streams
about how people just don't understand
that he's not scamming anyone is just
messing with the insurance companies
to help fund more research and since
this stream i've i've learned a lot more
about the topic and it was
totally scary that's the talking point
of all these pharmaceutical companies
who
jacked the price up like 100 times they
always say the same thing that he was
saying and
i guess he convinced some people that
that's true but yeah what they say is
oh well by raising the price a hundred
times we make it more accessible
which is like a total like double speak
counterintuitive
but they say it gives us more money for
research and it helps us subsidize
people who can't afford it
except that there's actually no evidence
of any of these guys giving it out for
free like they supposedly say they do
well and also the people that pay for it
is health insurance and government and
social security
so it ends up costing taxpayers like a
billion dollars yeah or more probably a
lot more
but at any rate um and he also it wasn't
in that clip but i remember
in that interview um he was like i'll
get six months that was his essay
right and it's seven years i think this
one takes
a little more than six months and they
took money and they took the wu-tang
album
i mean there you have it there you have
it his story is one that's just so
fascinating that
he was became so notorious like he
he said it in this interview and he's
right there's way bigger offenders than
he is that are way more powerful and way
more wealthy and way more
i would say well i don't know about way
more but they are predatory on a larger
scale
yeah they have avoid scrutiny but
somehow he was
made notorious by the media i guess
because he's put himself out there
probably
yeah sacrificed the anonymity that the
other guys
right like cherish in exchange for being
like
a meme lord yeah yeah and the public guy
so you know i think
he wanted to be a cool edgy yeah yeah he
paid the ultimate price
it is an interesting thing though
because i mean his big mistake in a way
was just
being honest about what he was doing
like he just he was
it's kind of weird i mean you know
trying to make that argument that it
wasn't fraud i mean obviously the court
did not agree with that
yeah um but but just you know
in principle raising the money and
everything you know he he
what he said often times was just you
know all these companies do this
i agree he's like i agree you know no
that wasn't they are all under
investigations now
maybe not all but a lot of them are well
he lost in the court of public opinion
and that's why everyone
went after him but we asked for hillary
clinton's dna too
oh that's why oh my god that's great
that's the reason he ended up going to
prison
is because he was on probation and then
he made a tweet
sarcastically asking anyone to get a
sample of hillary clinton's dna
so he could clone her yeah he said i
have the sequences
he was a threat to public safety but
actually he what he ended up going to
prison for had nothing to do with the
medicine it was
he defrauded investors of a of a uh
hedge fund yeah amazing stuff
well yeah it's like you're involved in
so many
shady things you wanted prison for the
one no he's the good guy
yeah he's like according to him always
remember shkreli for
rip harambee yeah let's let's pull that
up because that is
uh generally i'd watch a shkreli movie
that's probably coming um wait what does
that mean wait you would watch oh yeah i
would watch
let's let's do it and this is literally
strange he's a fascinating guy
yeah and and i'll tell you what every
time you he's streaming or something
he's always sitting alone home by
himself like he's like the loneliest
dude ever
it's pretty sad yeah but here he is
trolling cbs
now further away you talk about being
upset harambe who is
the gorilla that was killed at the
cincinnati zoo
you on twitter talk about caring so much
about him
that the life meant so much
the cincinnati zoo has come out and
asked people to stop using memes and
you've
you've used a lot of memes in social
media
how is that expecting by doing that when
you're asking
to stop in order to honor him sure so as
a sort of moonlighting scientist you
know i
i work a lot with non-human primates we
call them in the labs nhps so
any rhesus monkeys capuchins all the way
up to the higher orders
my brother and i especially uh have this
deep fondness for
for animals uh that are so close to
humans uh so remarkably close in fact
there are bonobos that can even
communicate with you on a one-to-one
level and tell jokes and be sarcastic
and funny and even flirt with you
it's unbelievable how human-like these
creatures are and the idea that we just
shot this animal in cold war
is the argument
to be honest it's painful to even talk
about this but let's
get back to the issue which is that in
in this country i don't think we value
non-human primate life
um the way we should i think these
animals actually should have rights
believe it or not if they did martin
they wouldn't be able to be used in the
pharmaceutical industry i don't think
they should think about
i don't think they should be you know i
i do a lot of van i've i've
i've overseen the death of thousands of
these animals
whether baby dogs or or rats and many
times
you've over pharmaceutical
executive has uh pfizer probably kills a
million animals here it's completely
true
it's painful you know if that does but i
can't tell if she's serious or not i
can't either
but it's like because actually i do
agree with what he's saying but
when it's such a troll it's hard to get
a read on when you talk about that
it feels like it is very it's a moral
decision it's it's how you feel morally
and yet when you talk about drug prices
when we were talking earlier and
and i know you're saying it should go to
the insurance companies it's it's up to
the insurance companies
but why not have that same moral
compassion for the way the system is i
have more moral compassion you know i
mean uh i think that
uh there's a lot of there's for instance
seven thousand rare diseases
there's only five or six companies in
the world that care about those diseases
the pfizers the mercs the astrazenecas
they care about the big sellers
but there's dying kids friends of mine
like the culver brothers three kids with
pecan i invented the first drug ever for
pecan
and these three kids they're staring at
their death sons they're teenagers
and uh i'm fighting my butt off to save
them
uh and i need money to do that investors
don't care for these little diseases and
so forth so
i think a lot more compassion than most
people think that's why i'm in the drug
business
but at the same time a non-human being
it also happens to be the most
lucrative yeah but at any rate rest in
peace around me yeah
went down the scarely hole a little bit
too far yeah and finally my favorite top
moment is dis doctor disrespect jumping
through the roof and here we have it
yeah all right let's see yeah let's see
there you have it knocked his way
knocked his hair back a little i don't
have any
hairline it's just hold on a second
look at me i forgot i got all dressed up
like that i need to do something in that
character
that character is great professor
prophecy yeah
we may have another clip of prophecy oh
we have one coming up well
this was a pretty special episode all
right
um god we got to do something i like
that getup
but you know worth mentioning is that a
lot of people
criticized us by the way i don't have
any problems showing he's clearly
shown himself out of costume now as many
of you have seen
but a lot of people were angry because
in fact they were even saying
oh this is the highlight yeah um they
were even saying that
we purposely yeah which is such
which is i i always resented that
because you can't explain why first of
all
what you're talking about what happened
oh at the end of the episode we always
go to like a slate and go to the wide
and so as soon as immediately as the
interview is done he takes off his wig
and glasses and you see him
out of character but we do that at the
end of every episode and i
i had no way to know that he was gonna
that he was gonna immediately take
everything off immediately
yeah our attention i didn't just did
that right um yeah it's not actually in
the episode because we cut it out it was
only in the twitch
while we were still on twitch um yeah
actually somebody
submitted uh stoxing uh him
doxing him as their worst moment in the
email
so i actually do have that clip because
somebody re-uploaded it
which but since then he is showing
himself yeah yeah a bunch of times
even before by the way even before yeah
right yeah there were already but hey
what can you say there's uh peop there's
always someone to complain
it was not intentional no of course that
people always assumed the worst
i found they did it on purpose yeah
it was a huge plot yeah that's the only
reason and i
went okay we're over now take off your
wig
so there you have it now i've got two
worst moments to share with you guys
they're selected by you these are
selected by me okay now first of all
worst moment we go way way back to our
first live episode
i'm sure you guys have all seen this
joji memed on me so
the way this was framed up just set me
up
we were like hours in i was so drunk at
this time
we were just chit chatting i think we
were talking about how
like in the animal kingdom like look at
shredder he's like he's a serial rapist
yeah okay our dog shredder goes to the
dog park
no seriously he he goes out there and
he'll [ __ ] anything that moves
he doesn't ask for consent he'll try and
my only point is that
back in the day human beings like
neanderthals or whatever earlier form
even apes they're out there they're i
don't know that they're they [ __ ] they
you know what i'm saying yes all right
yes right okay okay does that make sense
in a way it was just like nothing
research
just some stupid like conversation right
which is always
what people get upset about
we're just a couple of people shooting
the [ __ ] all right just a [ __ ]
idiot i didn't pretend to be anything
more than just a [ __ ] idiot and in
this case a drunk idiot
but that being said i don't think anyone
was actually offended by this but
um it was just funny how it played out
so here i am talking about that
or apes or whatever right our art watch
neanderthals
cousins were probably just raping like
crazy so there's definitely there's some
neanderthals like
in us to like conquer men want to like
right so
it's you know women are in a nature
setting
like to be conquered it came out
weird and it was super it came out weird
and it was a super long styling yeah
yeah and actually the most brilliant
part about it
yeah the most brilliant part about this
is that i'm sure he didn't know his face
was in
pure silence
[Laughter]
that was funny yeah man you got me good
yeah look at that shot oh yeah it's
still
i still see this posted all the time
yeah yeah i don't think i'll ever live
that one
he got me good and then there's i have
an honorable mention this is a new
this is a new moment and i can't tell if
it's
the best or worst
so here we are entering a new moment
[Laughter]
into the lexicon i saw this on the
subreddit
someone who follows my dad on twitter
now you know when somebody likes
something on twitter it goes up on their
feed
so someone decided to follow my dad on
twitter
and he posted this on the subreddit and
dad i love you but you got to know some
things you just
you can't do you're a public figure now
dad
gary liked uh you've still got a few
hours left
on abby snaps to see how sexy yesterday
was it's a
girl eating out another girl
[Laughter]
dad you don't have to like like like you
don't have to like porn at least if
you're gonna look at it
you don't have to slam a like on it you
got ted cruz yeah
my dad got ted cruz did you tell him
that you discovered this or is it
i showed it to him it was okay i said i
said dad just so you know
is he watching the stream right now you
think probably probably right i said dad
just so you know you already don't have
to like it
because it shows up on other people's
feet he tried to play it off cool he's
like
he said something like freedom with a
bunch of exclamation marks
such a legend and uh but
dad you finally look at porn you don't
have to like it but i can just imagine
this
poor guy who followed who decided to
follow my dad
and he's just scrolling his twitter feed
and now all of a sudden he likes
such an old people facebook thing
[Laughter]
oh man that's so brutal i can't decide
if it's better for the worst but there
you have it gary
um so i will now pass it off to you ela
you want to switch seats with me or no i
mean
it's so it's just two links i don't
think
so set aside so well it's kind of a
rough change from the last one um
i guess one of my favorite moments i
don't know if it's like favorite it's
weird to describe it but
having total biscuit on the show and um
later that year he passed away so
that was just a
surreal i guess experience to have here
and he talked about
cancer and that's hold up yeah having
him on here i'm so
thankful that we had the opportunity to
have him on the uh
so on the show when we did seriously
so here's a little excerpt that uh from
from him talking about living with
stage four cancer let's make sure that
time counts for something
and a lot of it is also you assume at
this age you've got
well i've got 50 60 years of the family
what if you didn't
well you know you don't know how long
you've got so
you know made me want to try and be a
better dad there's no doubt about that
you know i wanted to connect more with
my stepson
than i have and i've been doing that i
wanted to connect more with my wife
make sure that we get a good you know we
get a good run out of it
i intend to be around when i'm [ __ ]
100 years old
we'll be still bitching about video
games if i can be
but sometimes there might be something
outside of my control that
you know maybe fighting isn't enough
maybe that's just not enough to keep
going but if that's the case then you've
got to make sure that you spend the time
you've got
in the best way you can and even then
it's not like
it changes you overnight like you still
want to go read reddit comments you
still want to go
picture people on twitter like you can't
change a habit of a lifetime but
there's something in the back of your
mind that said do you have something
better to do
you know and maybe that that does change
you over time i think
well and somberly he did pass away
i think like five or six months or maybe
even less
yeah something like that yeah it really
shocked me yeah
i just i i mean he seemed i mean i know
he was in pain
and he was on chemo and he was very i
mean
he's very optimistic guy he's a fighter
yeah that's the thing about this disease
you
it doesn't show like you don't you the
person looks the same
right so you just don't see the decline
in their status and it was the same with
my dad up until the last moment it
looked healthy
like it looked fine he didn't even lose
his hair nothing looks the same
yeah so it's shocking when it happens
yeah but i thought it would be cool to
remember him today absolutely yeah
i had watched him all growing up i mean
like he was the starcraft guy
and i was i played a ton of starcraft
growing up uh and so
that was surreal to even have him in
there at all
and then to hear him talking uh about
his disease like that and so openly and
with so much optimism it was that was a
that was a special one that was cool
[Music]
yeah i cherish that i look at the
picture of us on the wall
like somewhat regularly yeah
and it's a loss what i remember from
that interview was he kept saying like
you know
five of my days are bad and two of them
are good and that's enough for me yeah
yeah you know make those two comment
[Music]
yeah he left a hole in the gaming
community too that hasn't really been
filled i feel like
it's such a unique voice yeah that is
definitely true
um well
god bless him him and uh carl jackson
which was daughter
oh my god that one was so [ __ ]
heartbreaking
um all happened at the same year
i don't think we've ever talked about
carl did we
we may have mentioned him briefly
he was a fan who had a rare type of
cancer that
ate fat cells in your body super rare
so there's very little research about
how to cure it
right and he actually was a
was a ch i would say a little chunky
like originally before he had cancer
kind of a larger
guy and by the time i met him he
i mean he looked like
um
like anorexic wow and so
he had this awful rare form of cancer
that was just eating all of his
uh fat cells away until he just perished
from
just wasted away but but he wrote us an
email and we reached out and we sent him
gifts he was a huge fan of teddy fresh
and like he was a big fan of ours and i
had played pub g with him a couple of
times
and we kept in regular contact and he
was such a sweet
[ __ ] dude he was such a sweet dude
it's such a great
outlook you know and i hadn't talked to
him for oh yeah and he went to like his
only dream was like to go to disneyland
and
he had this big uh make-a-wish
foundation send them to disney
and we sent him like 500 bucks or
something for spending money
because his fan he had like a single mom
there was it was like the saddest [ __ ]
ever his dad
wasn't in the picture so
he just two weeks go by and i haven't uh
talked to him and then someone
another youtuber who was in touch with
him
just sent me like a dm or something like
hey i just want to let you know
in case you didn't hear that carl passed
away
i was like damn it's [ __ ] so tragic
he was like 18 years old
god are you looking for a picture i'm
trying to send it here if you go to the
email
ethan yeah he sent his
twitter oh there you go oh yeah this is
this is yeah he was active on twitter
and he was really loving
because people started um following him
on twitter
and he was getting some like really
positive
support and attention i mean you can see
how
yeah how thin he had become
and um one day he just stopped cancer of
fat cells
i've never heard of that i mean i guess
you said it's super rare super rare
that's crazy
huh and one day he just his twitter
stopped
and what was that that was that i see
his mom tweeted something
i didn't see that i think this was the
last thing i remember saying was him
being like
i totally didn't pre-order this which is
the avenger
super hand toy yeah
he was a sweet kid man he was a [ __ ]
real sweet dude
not a part of the podcast but
something that definitely we experienced
sure but eli you do have
oh you just have the worst now yeah so
what's your worst one
how do you top that
very optimistic person today um
though maybe i okay so the worst one was
actually when i went to israel all right
this actually works out because your
worst is actually pretty funny
um i went to israel twice when my dad
wasn't feeling well but the first time
uh he didn't stayed and
kind of [ __ ] it up on the podcast
getting drunk
and talking [ __ ] about some guys
that he shouldn't have and um so then i
we scheduled that i will call in from
israel
so here it is that's the moment
hello ela
what's up oh god thank you guys for the
picture
you didn't you don't know anything about
this right you didn't you're not updated
on all this
ethan i left for one day
left for one day and
everything is ruined liz it's not my
fault it's your fault
you know what's gonna happen you think
that i can handle myself without a care
you leave me in here i can't i can't
deal with this you leave me in a room
with eric and jack and two bottles of
hennessy
whose idea was that how many pizza
slices did you have
a lot dude
[Laughter]
that's all i was upset about
he was like [ __ ] this [ __ ] you just
didn't lose that weight
elo i'm sorry for smoking by the way i'm
never i'm not smoking anymore i'm done
that's the last cigarette you'll see me
smoke on this podcast or on the street
not entirely true but i don't know very
well i think i've had like three
cigarettes since then okay yeah ontario
very low
good so anyway
dude did you were you listening to that
yeah
that was actually a great way
well there you have it ela's best and
worst
um very nice now up next we've got dan
and ian here with uh let me see here
we've got the
where is this yeah there's best and
worse dan why don't we
change spots that'll be that'll be
better dan has a few actually
let me go down to your spot so
we all have best and worse now dan here
you go
there might have been some overlap but i
don't think so i don't think there is
all right so um
all right so yeah this is great this uh
this first one
um this was really shortly after
um coming to work with you guys i want
to say it was maybe the second episode
um that i ever did um which was such a
trait because
it was the episode we did with
which you know legend i'd grown up
watching jackass
i love that [ __ ] and um and
you know a week into this gig you know
getting to hang out with stevo all day
was like this is pretty cool
um and so back then uh we did the
ad reads live all right
i can't believe we ever did that yeah
crazy uh so they did the adwords live
and then you know
you guys wanted to take a break um to
use the restroom
and he was like oh i'm good and it's
like well you know you can hang out and
i think we
he had like an ipad or something with
the twitch chat going
and so uh he saw somebody in the twitch
chat
say hey what's uh what's your craziest
drug story and immediately
he launches into this [ __ ] wild story
about a time
at like because you know he's clean now
he doesn't do any of this but he was
just
you know this was maybe 10 years prior i
don't think i ever watched this
yeah we didn't yeah oh well this is my
first time i actually have it
time stamped to the moment you guys
walked back in but here we go should you
hear the whole story yeah let's [ __ ]
watch it i've never watched it all right
it's our own content for christ's sake
congratulations my best drug story
oh my god okay i'll tell you i'll tell
you
oh my god this is [ __ ] up he's alone
in the room
you know i thought about asking him that
question but i was like he probably got
said all the time you know but
i was determined that it just wasn't
[ __ ] funny
um i'm going to shut this door now
what a professional yeah i know was so
helplessly addicted to cocaine it was
insane like
if i ran out i would call this drug
dealer
and uh if i was waiting for a call from
him i'd be like
using my cell phone as a pillow
so that when it was god vibrated like it
would wake up
oh yeah i need drugs now if i went to uh
if i called up the drug dealer and if he
didn't answer
i would just [ __ ] show up at his
place i would just go there
and be like ah when i got to his place i
would i would
try the door sometimes it was open and i
would just walk in
and sometimes it wasn't open and that
was upsetting
um this guy okay this drug dealer
wasn't just a drug dealer he was also
like a hardcore addict and when it came
i'm talking about cocaine this guy would
inject cocaine he would shoot up
and for some reason i never injected
anything yeah
some reason that i just don't understand
about
people who shoot up cocaine is that with
their syringe
they squirt their own blood all over the
place i mean this guy's apartment
it was all like i don't think that's
normal stevo
[ __ ] concealing the furniture this
[ __ ] had
just his with his syringes
what squirt all over the place blood
that is so [ __ ] and
sometimes when i showed up and i would
walk in i'd find the guy like sitting
there with like
with literally needles [ __ ] hanging i
feel like it was hanging out of his neck
one time you know sitting there and i
walked in he was like
[Laughter]
[ __ ] it was gnarly and um you know i did
whatever i wouldn't
judge him i'd be like oh yeah hey man
i'll give me some coke and i would buy
like a bunch you know like um
god [ __ ] always buy like quite a lot
and um i'm sure it was long [ __ ] time
i showed up his door was not it was it
wasn't locked and it was open
i walked in it wasn't in the living room
it was in this back bedroom
it was like a guest house kind of a deal
and uh
it wasn't like an apartment but it was
it was like the guest house he went
like through the back of someone's
driveway and then he was in in the back
and i walked in so
he's in his bedroom in the back and like
the dude's like he wasn't dead
obviously but like but he was not
responsive
you know he was so he had i guess been
awake for so many days that there's no
[ __ ] waking this guy up and he's like
i'm like trying to wake him up yo i need
i need [ __ ] drugs you know like
hey he's just there's no getting this
guy up so
so [ __ ] man like i just finally like
okay [ __ ] you know he's just sleeping so
heavily i'm just not gonna get him up so
i went myself
into his living room to the table where
he would weigh out all his drugs
and there was from him weighing so
this guy sold so much [ __ ] drugs that
on the table itself
there was just like a [ __ ] residue of
cocaine just built up and i was looking
at it like i knew
that if i took a card that uh
that i could just i could scrape up like
the gnarliest pile of cocaine
and i'm just like i'm just gonna go i
want drugs and i'm just [ __ ] i'm gonna
go
[ __ ] help myself i'm gonna go scrape
so now i go and i sit down at the table
and i'm looking at there's cocaine all
over it but like i said the [ __ ]
squirted his own blood everywhere
so it's like cocaine with blood
like a little like splatters like thin
like you know
and i'm like [ __ ] this is a terrible
idea like
this is [ __ ] bad and i'm like
and i just start scraping up [ __ ]
cocaine
and like i can like visibly like in the
pile i'm scraping like
i can see specks of blood
and this is this is how [ __ ] bad i
was
addicted sat there [ __ ] snorted the
motherfucker's
blood
asking for my craziest drug story that
was on my i wanted to ask you that
well i don't have to watch the video i
just draw i just dropped it
and stephen literally said is an
incredible storyteller yeah he's great
he's sober now yeah no he's feeling
great he looks really healthy
too he looks really healthy and he looks
like he was reacting to people in the
room like making eye contact
even though you guys were not basically
with the spirits
he had talked about how he used to see
spirits right
yeah um but wow i was kept that was i
was completely captivated
that was like four minutes i never knew
four minutes
in my mind i was always like why did he
snort blood okay right i was like
i thought that yeah what's the setup
well there you have it there you have it
well i'm glad yeah i didn't realize you
guys hadn't seen it at all so i'm glad
we uh we got to review that
yeah and like you guys like i said you
had gone out to the bathroom so i was
just sitting
in that other room and my jaw was just
dropped as he's telling the story i'm
like is he [ __ ] for real right now
so uh so that was pretty wonderful i
watched i watched the documentary about
stevo during those early years and he
was
he was wild he was not well that was all
serious
yeah i mean oh yeah i don't doubt that
at all
yeah wow yeah so um so that was
definitely
uh a great early memory of uh working
with yeah that was episode 12 of the
podcast and i think
i had come in on 11 so that yeah that
was my second episode
i think you went from joey salads to
having stevie yeah so
one end to the other right there um so
then
actually my next uh was was also the
martin shkreli thing um
so we've already we've already gone down
that rabbit hole a little bit
uh what else do we got here um
all right this is don't don't judge me
is a little corny but
this is not generally one of my favorite
moments to the podcast
i've got a little announcement
not really an announcement just
something i wanted to talk about and
just to give some context you guys
didn't tell us either
but this i i found out the same time as
all of you so
uh so this was a pretty special moment
but it may
be that and also your delivery is
hilarious there's a new thing
of the thickening heel is going to be
thickening up here soon
what does that mean what i'm trying to
say is that ila won't be drinking
alcohol
if she's responsible what i'm trying to
describe
oh that's me sorry oh jesus
[Laughter]
how long was that going oh it just
started like just you know you turned it
off immediately okay and flashback
right there right like no
um there's
two stripes
[Laughter]
she's cooking something up
anyone it's a cinnamon roll with
frosting
ela it's weird
[Laughter]
i think we literally found out the day
before
[Laughter]
well it's we we don't
know yet if anything's going to go wrong
she's pregnant it was so hard to say you
know because
we've been dying for sure that's very
sweet of you danny yeah yeah
that genuinely was that was a special
heartwarming yeah
that's good well she is very the
thickening has happened
can you show like over just do like a
tight like
make your shirt tight oh look at that
can you turn it across the camera let me
see
oh we can see it on the watch it's hard
to tell but when
there's a bump it's funny because you're
like halfway through and you
i mean these next four months are going
to go faster
accelerates you're going to accelerate
from here on out yeah no but i was
saw ila the other day when she was
getting dressed or like just yesterday
and as she's putting her shirt on i'm
like holy [ __ ]
pregnant there's a baby in there yeah
no it's weird yeah that's great and then
uh this
i'll make i had a few more but uh i'll
make this my last of my
favorite um this is uh to this day
my favorite line that's ever been
uttered on this podcast
i don't think it'll ever be topped
honestly i'm curious what is it
episode 39 with post malone looks so
exhausting it is yeah i look like [ __ ]
no you look amazing
you're killing it bro i love that you
just the great thing is that you just
embrace
you're authentic dude you're who you are
like yeah you just [ __ ] you're
you're killing it bro just a guy exactly
just a guy with beautiful blue eyes
right well then i guess that means you
are more than just a guy to be honest
because i didn't have that
i'm really just the guy your eyes look
like hamburgers
yeah that is amazing i don't know why
that's so [ __ ] funny to me but i
think of that
regularly that's a line that's a very
original line yeah
yeah and they do okay expert village
your eyes are like blueberries yeah i
want to eat them
there's the that tom petty song right
the brown eyed girl
dan morrison van wyk and marshall thank
you zach was quick
but famously uh post malone has a new
track coming out on his new album called
hamburger eyed boy
[Laughter]
it's about me that's awesome congrats
um okay and then uh and then i just i
have
one worst moment that i need to put up
there um
i legitimately still have nightmares
about this occasionally and that's not
a joke um i have like stress nightmares
about work and we are streaming sure you
could guess something
oh my god this was our first
on youtube the first time on youtube
to come over youtube and give it a shot
and see what it feels like because
it keeps
is
what happened which made this so great
is that it was our first
live episode on youtube which means that
because we were live streaming on twitch
so if we had a mistake like this
we could just start over right and then
cut it up yeah
so this was the first time that it was
like we gotta actually nail the slide
and i think part of it too is that you
know i usually double check all the
computers and and would check for this
kind of stuff but because it was the
first time on youtube i had a million
new
like it wasn't routine like it was the
first day of the new setup
and so my mind was a million places and
didn't see that you had a
stream open and uh whoops hey
look we got 1.2 million views yeah i
guess it worked out somehow people
powered through it
that makes me feel better that 1.2
million people have seen
me feel better um you're too hard on
yourself dan
yeah well you know especially that was a
disaster
it does it's like a feeling of an
anxiety attack like on the camera
yeah yeah exactly yeah it was a disaster
it sounds like an anxiety attack right
and then
after the episode we go and we see how
bad is it we're like oh we're like oh
how bad could it be
and it keeps going and it keeps going no
i remember i remember you guys
when i told you i was you were like you
know
after the episode it was like hello how
bad is it and i was like
pretty bad well it was fun it's funny in
retrospect yeah
i guess but um but yeah i mean i'll
sometimes have
like just this past week um yeah it was
the night before the charity stream
no i didn't dream about that but i had a
dream that our audio board
all the settings got erased like five
minutes before show
which um anybody that's done audio would
know that that's like
you know two hours of reset that would
need to
to happen and so i'm glad to know you're
having nightmares about work
that means you really care i do i do you
know
yeah exactly the test the next day or
whatever naked so
well cherished memories cherished
memories and not so cherished memories
so yeah so that
that was that was my lineup and we got
cool we got him
in here yeah why don't you queue up yeah
why don't you guys switch teeth
i left my sodie in the other room
you sure this is not it no i mean
so many saudis so many soda pops
uh dan oh i see where it is yeah you
should just be the list right below
there
gotcha
that air all right
so this one was dan let's listen
early on when i started working here and
this
moment i think took us all caught us all
by surprise
all right brad berry showed up wait hold
on
what is this clip it only has two
thousand views this is way early on the
channel the highlight channel's live one
of the first
videos this is gonna be the lowest which
by the way highlight channel just hit a
million subscribers like two days ago
that is so cool because we all created
that highlight channel together
yeah less than a year ago because people
were
stealing our clips and posting us we're
like what the hell we should do it
right and uh the explosion there
has been phenomenal yeah and it's so
cool that we've all built that
together yeah you you guys were all here
from the inception of that channel
mm-hmm
that's our fourth i mean dan and ian are
the guys who actually cut it cut the
highlights and loads management
75 percent ian yeah i would give him a
lot of credit there that yeah he
he's the highlight king yeah yeah with
some of the
slick thumbnails yeah the thumbnails
have been fire lately
our thumbnail game has been improving
yeah you guys have been doing it it's an
acquired talent yeah you guys are
getting better and better at it
but um that's our fourth million
subscribed channel right that's another
button
now the button to pawn off when we go
broke
[Laughter]
what were you going to say i mean we do
the toast now well that i i feel like i
i peaked a little bit ago with that papa
john shooting papa john in the back of
the head
i don't know
yeah exactly oh we toasting are we doing
this should we toast when he when ian's
done
we can let's let's enjoy some orange
soda while you uh
i don't what well because because you
mentioned it oh so as
ian discusses his um
his uh best and worst we shall enjoy
is this cristal what year is this that's
vintage uh
2016 because i don't know who drinks
orange soda it's probably been sitting
on the shelf
about that long thank you this is a rose
right or is this crystal rose
this is orange yeah oh rain
this is a what is the squirt crush
uh it's it's fanta there's a nice fruity
aroma i'm picking up
here go ahead can you drink
you can have a little of that since you
are pregnant but not too much
that's probably true about soda they're
like don't drink that [ __ ] if you're
pregnant
you gotta let it open up yeah let it let
it let it air out a little bit
yeah you want to dive right into that
cheers guys
to one million on the on the highlights
highlights
into a great first 100 episodes together
yes indeed
and thank you to all the viewers and
listeners yeah
i think that turned really
tastes funny you don't like prime to me
baby
[Music]
does uh sarah and zach has a cup in the
background oh you guys
do yes yes we did let's see a little
backstage
[Music]
[Laughter]
and sarah yes cheers guys
a great year to a great celebration of
you know there's six people here that i
really like i guess that includes i'm
glad you didn't say five
and then i'll let you decide starting to
count like wait who but what
who's left out five no not including
myself okay
oh okay wait why are we confused about
no you're not confused you said it right
yeah how did you mean wait
okay he was just saying if you had said
you had said the wrong number and then
left us
confused because six includes you right
it's weird to say i really like yourself
i didn't mean to say that
do people really like themselves then
you should like love yourself
i know people say that you know what
yeah i mean nobody actually it's weird
to be like
but you gotta say it
i remember we were all panicking on this
one because we we had no idea
what was going to walk through the door
if mo and ethan bradberry were gonna
just be like completely
quiet yeah you know if they're gonna
engage right
and then they turned out to be just
absolute legends
well there's a little backstory actually
because we didn't know what to expect
and um somebody rolled outside to greet
them was it you ian
uh it wasn't me i think we saw out the
window actually
wasn't it i don't think you could see
somebody went outside i think and
maybe it was me it was me it was
definitely me
i went out to go meet them and i saw
them in the parking lot putting on the
spiderman
outfits and i was like oh my god
they're surprised i came inside and i
was like oh my god you guys are
yourself do you remember this now yeah
um i even and i remember like we bought
donuts before and they came
with their own they were they were on
the beams man they knew what was
up they came to play so
[Laughter]
we rolled out the carpet form here
i think the only guest that ever got the
red carpet treatment right
yep by the way i don't know why i love
these backstage shots
me too i
[Music]
we should have played the kids music
instead of that's true
we were all obsessed with ethan trap
berry as i still am
actually all right
shout out to cool songs ethan does his
own thing oh wow i'm not pregnant
i was afraid that uh all right i was
afraid that ethan was just gonna lay
on the couch yeah our blood kind of rain
cold right here
it's like oh [ __ ] where are they going
spidey come on dog all of my mine is
this one is spidey such a troublemaker
yeah that was a good moment yeah that
was pretty great
they they were very very on board
surprise
surprising that was the beginning of the
turn
the rhythm the paradigm shift in the
life of ethan bradbury and
joe and mo joe mo broadway
because since then they've gone full
meme mode to like a complete extreme
right and now they comment on every
instagram post
that any of us ever make since that
episode they don't miss a single
they don't miss the post they do not
miss a post and he always said
ethan writes stuff that doesn't make
sense yeah he'll just go like slamming
on everything
it's just it's great god bless his soul
you know sometimes
i mean i remember when you made the
pregnancy announcement he actually
was pretty sweet with his comments
that's true yeah yeah
what did he say i was just
congratulating you guys it seemed very a
real congratulations yes
it wasn't a slammin this baby
oh look at me we've got the prophet yeah
this was when uh
the doctor showed up to do something
with his character that looks so good
professor prophecies got to make a
comeback
so this is when you introduced the doc
he's someone who i respect and
appreciate
and i'm also going to take him out
because i'm the three time
and i'm the prof and i'm here to
prophesy the end of the doc
dan bring this coward in bring this
coward in
yeah minecraft casual good gaming okay
first of all i have a castle in
minecraft if my bullets didn't come into
my server and tear it down you would
have been
in awe i replicated the tng enterprise
in minecraft and you're going to [ __ ] on
that
that's why they called me the three
times i did bring you some collector
item
t-shirts and i don't know if i even want
to hand them to you now
okay
now you got a fan girl now you got a fan
girl take a look at those
take a look at it frankly i can't see
i'm going to put these down
you can't see in the google prototype
scopes with the version of those things
there are some earlier okay what do we
got here that was good
that was really fun that was yeah that
was just a fun that was one of my
favorite episodes i think he was just so
entertaining yeah i was so nervous
about interviewing him because he's so
deep in character that
it was just um i was afraid it was gonna
be a minefield of trying to get him to
say
yeah anything interesting but he
actually he he did great i mean yeah
he like never broke character but but he
still managed to be
kind of real through the lens of the
character it was it was good
yeah i enjoyed that yeah i said uh so
another one that i had was
when we had sean sean evans first yeah
yeah exactly that's nice it's like got
to look at you you got a [ __ ] beard
and everything yeah yeah
yeah when i saw this i was like we got
to do a mini hot dog
oh yeah you and alex were getting
creamed in the background
it was it was rough i was not
anticipating well i was
at the time because you now like spicy
food because of this right like this
kind of like broke the seal
yeah i remember it was we we knew this
about ian that he like never ate spicy
food and then we fourteen had like a hot
cheeto would knock me on my ass
so you know this was a big jump oh this
this was so that's like a lightweight
cream yeah
like and two because the taste is kind
of pleasant at first
[Laughter]
it feels like i was tea bagged by satan
it looks like you were tea bag
how are you feeling alice i'm good your
face is [ __ ] up
that's like crying i was dying
back there that was rough that was so
fun yeah
that was one of my favorite episodes
because we have always been such fans of
hot ones
yeah and then to get actually got to
pick his brain a little bit
yeah on how he interviews people yeah
um that was actually i think the first
time i
showed my face on that was the reveal we
had the meme where we never saw your
face
yeah although we didn't really never
shut like we've shown we have blown it
once before i think
uh or it was maybe even on the
raspberries by
joey salad who was it joey yeah yeah and
like his vlog he showed and somebody on
the subreddit
discovered it was such an ancient meme i
almost didn't even
yeah i really that was great doing a
little mini hot ones yeah that was
cool another i liked uh
when eric brought on his uh conspiracy
closet
segment ah the roker clip oh yes i love
love love this roker club
keep an eye on al keep an eye on now
this guy's a clone he's about to glitch
the [ __ ] out
of distance between the bodies these
other two on the right might also be
clones
one of the strangest thing uh things on
his on the history of television oh
weird
what is happening
because he's like and it's such a weird
face that yeah
it's not a natural relaxed look at him
no yeah it's so weird but
it does seem like somebody said like his
trigger word
and he went into debug mode or something
i think
half a second off oh yeah and the intro
of his segment is just so great
that's awesome we should get another we
should get another
episode going yeah of er maybe season
two
there you go that would be fun man yeah
eric's always a blast to have on yeah
he's a great presence i love her it's
time to reboot the conspiracy classes
yeah i didn't know it meant that much to
you even but no
to this day people like not
constantly but i'll see comments of like
please bring it back it was so good
yeah we should i really love how he
prepared a segment it was
it really worked yeah yeah right and uh
this was the another shkreli one but
this was just to show
the live episode we did which i thought
was one of the funnest
most enjoyable ones we've done but also
extremely stressful you know
oh yeah you guys yeah you guys in the
crew i mean that was
it took so much work and and you guys
were grinding hard
that was a lot put that together we had
extra
because it wasn't just through the live
show it was also streaming it
recording it all this first time ever
doing it out of our studio which i've
done a lot of remote
events so that was my job before i came
and worked for you guys but it had been
a while
and i was used to working with like a
production truck
yeah and like you know and but uh but we
pulled it off and i mean
we did you know mostly like any hitches
really i will say
well
improv why do you guys have a 50 [ __ ]
projector
like just spend a little more money
barely got time on the stage to
get used to it like only an hour before
they had a meeting that's all right that
we got kicked out of the venue
yeah yeah so there were some
circumstances that made it
for the most part it was as smooth as
you could hope for yeah but zach
was calling in as jordan the right
fanboy yeah and he was coming on the
projector yes
that's right yes thanks
now i have nightmares about that one too
that wasn't that was out of control
because we tested it beforehand and it
worked yeah exactly there's only so much
you can do but
it uh it was a such a fun such a fun fun
time and
and so stressful it was just too
stressful that's why we haven't done it
again because we were like
that was amazing and i never want to do
it again kind of
we did want to do it again but we don't
want it it was like it's weird
we even had the idea of doing it once a
month i don't know oh my god
no yeah doing it as like kind of a
residency thing
i mean if we were maybe something to
consider in the future because if we do
it regularly then it becomes less
of a thing you know you get a routine on
how you do it and you get into a rhythm
and it's not so bad so
maybe someday in the future i mean it
was so fun it really was
a lot of fun we all went out afterwards
posted this out and like that that was
super fun
yeah so yeah but the the the thing is
like in the room the odd there was so
much laughter and joy in the room
that was uh yeah and everyone there was
a really great energy
but when you watch the vaude you don't
really get to feel that because
you don't hear the laughs in the crowd
as much as we did in the room
right which that was another aspect is
we the venue
did the audio and not that they did a
terrible job but they didn't necessarily
have uh
audience mics and so you know if we were
to do it again if we knew lesson learned
like the
mic the audience we should we should
yeah maybe we'll do another one next
year
it was uh oh and there was a proposal a
marriage
oh yeah oh and you know what we did
again we went
when we did kill tony they were in the
audience oh no way
and they came and said hi and we're like
oh [ __ ] you guys are married now that
was really difficult
that's awesome i'm yeah
to find the moment but yeah let's look
at this guy's bag
he's back judgment just came out what
part is this stand that yeah the audio
quality is the guy
man seven years in prison
i suspect if he wasn't such a troll he
probably won't be fine right
does he have the clip i don't know yeah
i think they're setting it up
playing uh our little meme at it exactly
it's gonna be i thought it was
oh yeah look you had everybody lift up
their cell phones
oh yeah dude look at that great camera
kind of these pretty precious animals
that's why we care so much about
harambee so we had danny come in too
yeah we actually had camo man this is
awesome this is really well shot
if you could make 100 million dollars
but you had to go to jail
how much time would you do is this
related to your situation oh
totally totally unrelated to this with
over 100 million dollars right now i'm
looking at uh
zero to six months six months and no
fine
that's right the so-called
[Music]
he lived the same way he was
walked up meaning it's it might be
you can't hear any laughter thank you
that was special yeah
yeah round of applause good job the
crowd was amazing yeah
the crowd was playing i mean they were
having a really good and you feel so
funny because like
you have such a uh sympathetic audience
right
and they're there for you and they love
you so it's like oh it's the best
[ __ ] crowd
yeah i can only imagine trying to
perform like jerry seinfeld oh my god
i can only imagine trying to do jokes
for people who don't know who you are
it's a tough game out there that's a
tough game
i think sarah put this one in as the
best her favorite moments
oh or one of her least favorite actually
i'm not sure
i don't know what is that thank you once
again yeah the dead mouse george
zimmerman
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh no i remember thinking
this is why i have a i have a straight
up name phobia yes
that's i had it before that and when i
say people's name i get
so stressed that i'm gonna say the wrong
thing i have like a mini panic attack
every time and i called him george
zimmerman
his name is joel zimmerman the right one
we were closed and the new album is
coming out the [ __ ] is it sure
you said george zimmerman because that's
a guy in florida who killed a dude
oh my god
we were already friends you were
supposed to cut it
you're supposed to have cut it all right
cut it just cut it
wow great idiot oh man
yeah great entry like totally nice
wow this was one of
one of my worst moments i think from the
show
here we go wait those are kanye's yeah
uh i got them on stockx i love shoes i'm
i'm in that way you can say but i buy i
buy the shoes that i really genuinely
like i
i and are those comfy yeah very yeah
good kanye's shoes are [ __ ]
you know our intern has fake easies on
really good instant regrets
[Laughter]
like your reaction was because i thought
it was like an
interesting um point of conversation to
note like
but then i was like oh i shouldn't oh
yeah
because i forget that you're so in the
kanye community yeah but did you feel
betrayed
i guess so i'm always like a rat in the
community like i was banned from the
floor
i couldn't get the real shoes i'm like
screwing around in the walls
of the kanye fan side so you know but
well okay because there is a silver
lining too yeah
yeah show them what you're wearing right
now as a result
as a result of me outing ian adidas
reached out and hooked ian up
no one else yep no one else so we're all
jealous actually let me
let me rephrase they said we want to
give you guys
yeezys who's up first and i
said it's got to be
and in fact they haven't sent us any
more years that was it
no it was difficult but we did get a
pair and
i am very grateful for that so what so
let me ask you this
would you are you happy that i added you
or would you prefer to go back and erase
that moment
well either way i have yeezys like where
i'm not outed those are real
everybody right so it's a win-win you
know it's a zero-sum sort of game
but i guess i have real ones now you had
real ones but
they're not real let me ask you this are
the real ones more comfortable than the
fake ones
it's a different materials different
different shoes
yeah yeah but how does it compare
because you've got fakes and you get
really i think they're pretty comfy
um i think they're yeah they're comfier
than the fake ones for sure it's the
right thing to say
and i and now i'm glad i'm gonna
unconvinced and now that his shoes are
more available than
you know there's no need to buy the fake
ones yeah so if you see me in any other
pair they're real
i swear don't look at don't get too
close
very
uh but those were my uh all of my
moments
best and worse so uh yeah thank you guys
that's it
that was fun let's see what else we got
here
wow we've seen it all
we've done it all right it was nice to
remember we had two hours
wow i had a lot to talk about yeah
well we've got one other do we are we're
going to take that collin from
debunkaroo
oh let me go get it while you're
preparing that i have a fan submission
okay remember you can always submit to
podcast
at h3h3productions.com if you have any
questions submissions videos
we want to you want us to watch et
cetera but this one came and even all of
these uh
best and worst moments people submitted
a lot it was very helpful
that was amazing thank you guys um but
this one comes from
jay dance in regards to our charity
live stream and i thought it was it was
very sweet and addressed one of the
points we were
wondering about so here i'll read it uh
hello everyone at the h3 my name is jay
dance and i'm a huge fan
of the podcast and got into podcasting
because of you guys i'm writing you guys
today
um because of the charity event podcast
you guys did yesterday with justin
rowland and alex hirsch
i am from paradise california and most
of my family and friends have lost
everything
due to the campfire i just want to say
thank you for doing this charity podcast
means so much to all of us the support
and help and then she goes on
oh and one more thing you guys should
you guys talked about
one more things you guys talked about
what you would take if you had a chance
to evacuate
and most of you said dog of course the
media has given backlash towards people
leaving their pets which on paper i
would have too
the truth is when the fire hit paradise
it was around 8 am
8 30 am so by that time most people had
already gone to work or
school and dropped their kids off at
school paradise being a small town
most people don't work in paradise and
commute out of town
in the surrounding cities like chico red
bluff riding etc
so when the fire hit paradise and when
it did hit it very quickly
people did not even have the time to go
back to paradise to get their pets or
any personal belongings
because it was you know that makes so
much sense i wanted to share this with
you guys
and that does actually explain it
anyway thanks for being awesome people
and i always look forward
to the show thank you so much jay dance
so that actually puts it even more in
perspective because yeah you go off to
work or school
you don't even have a chance to get not
only your pet but any of your belongings
so hard devastated if like i couldn't go
take care of shredder oh my god and you
know that something's up
that makes because i feel like a lot of
the videos i watched where people were
trying to drive back
into it was because of their pets and i
did wonder that so yeah
i mean god that's so heart-wrenching
like to not to feel helpless
like shredders in the house right and
you don't know if it's on fire like what
like i don't i would run into the fire
i guess that's what some people tried i
mean it's just like
such a betrayal and your poor pet is at
home scared
confused looking for you that's so
devastating mm-hmm
um i'm glad that yeah that this direct
relief can help anyone
well right and just to revisit because
dan is setting up a call with
with uh a person that paid a thousand
dollars
i want to urge you guys all link is in
the description it's below the sponsors
so just
open it up and you'll find the link
there to remember that you can donate
for another 10 days
to help everybody who lost their homes
in the fire and
um this goes directly to to support them
there's and so many incredible gifts
still available um some
with with bids so low that you have an
incredibly high chance of winning it
especially
all the original art that i would
heavily urge you guys to go
bid on let me see how we're doing
tiltify
if you just go to tiltify.com we're on
the issue oh nice it's been going up
since we started live streaming
um here we are 132
the rewards i'm telling you there's this
[ __ ] is just up for grabs all the
original art
is just like i think this one is the one
that had 80.
80 bucks this is an original alex hirsch
wait no not this one it was the original
justin roiland artwork by alex hershey
oh god he got sloppier and sloppier
no wonder nobody's bidding on that i
would still
wait that didn't eight dollars is that
what it was at yeah i don't know which
one
hold on the one that said eight dollars
justin's so
funny god it's still a justin royal and
original he doesn't make that
um why is it not letting me oh this is
why
i'll tell you which one was
eight bucks here let me give you the
rundown
if i can find it can i find it
original alex yo it's uh the the eight
bucks one is alex hirsch's
drawing of justin roiland which that
deserves to come on people that one's
amazing oh yeah that's a great one
yeah wait where's the door i don't have
the document
i have it open right now so can you
share it with ethan or wait i have a
link to it
you have it yeah that's weird
so here we go yes oh it's not letting me
look at this [ __ ] i can't click the tab
on the bottom it's hidden
what do you want to know though i'm
looking at it right now i think it wants
to show it
so here we go did you get the fan on the
phone dan i do he's on hold so oh let's
take the call okay you wanna take the
call now yeah all right stand by
i've got him in original alex hirsch you
should show all the crazy graphs that
sarah
put together oh yeah one [ __ ] ham on
on the graphics look at that the one
that i really like
is the um this is like hourly donation
rate
so you can see when justin justin justin
rally exactly
dude we dipped so hard wait no that's
right that's at the end of this okay
that's the end
so here we were hitting this midpoint
yeah
and we were like man there's no way
we're gonna make it there's
no way and then we were at like 75 here
and this was the rally that was justin
just
demanding in one hour go on yeah it
happened so that was actually our
biggest hour of the whole
stream the finale killed it he came in
like braveheart
um oh this is page two
just how much each uh reward was donated
by yeah
yeah don't go past this post okay i
better not that didn't happen
i i don't know what's past this boss
sarah but i'm scared you go to the
spirit realm
if you click that yeah that's right so
let's patch so who we got on the phone
here today so uh there's a gentleman who
goes by fifths
and he's a fan he's a big fan of the
podcast he's been watching a long time
and he um during the donation stream
donated a thousand bucks when he did the
shout out to have a caller uh call in
but he had an international number and
our phone system yeah that's right
our phone system wouldn't let us uh get
to them and so we had
kind of a technical issue getting
through to him so to make it up to him
we're talking to him today so
uh here is phipps right
resume call right now
fifths what's up
hey you oh hi
okay first of all thank you so much you
donated you helped us get to our hundred
thousand your legend i'm sorry we didn't
get to answer your call
during that live stream but i am good
you guys were popping you know
roiling the whole the whole gang it was
really crazy the whole podcast
it wasn't about the call specifically
you guys are doing this for a great
cause and i really appreciate what you
guys are doing
god bless thank you so much man you're
doing it i want to ask you
since we're in the spirit of uh sharing
our favorite moments do you have a
favorite moment
that uh as a as as a as a audience
member of the podcast
i mean you guys pretty much covered a
lot most of the moments
uh i mean the the ricky tikita
you know he was calling the the church
and he was going crazy with the
rick voice i was like whoa whoa whoa
calm down
like i didn't think that he would take
it that far i think it was like a little
you know goof and then you just stop it
you just kept on going and i really
loved it
yeah i was shocked watching that back
today actually how crazy that call was
that lady yeah no it was really awesome
like i really like
the thing is that what i love about the
podcast itself
is that you know you guys have this kind
of formula going on
but you get diversify in a way that you
have always these new elements coming in
so you have royal indian a couple of
times right but every time he comes in
there's something new added to the mix
like new elements
which is something as an audience member
like holy [ __ ] you know
damn thank you that's awesome to hear we
work hard it
sometimes doesn't maybe it's not easy to
spot but we've
i mean we try we work hard on the on the
show
and i'm glad to hear that that you
appreciate it and
we're working hard i'm hoping that um
when we come back for like 101 plus the
new season i want to call it in a month
i want to redo a lot of things and kind
of reimagine
what we do here and freshen it up a lot
i've got some fun ideas and
um awesome well one thing we talked
about oh
uh no i was just asking about like you
know because you have like two channels
right
so you got a little bit of the criticism
about kind of like how you're balancing
out the channels and everything
i don't really dig into it too much but
like you're putting a lot of
effort into the the podcast which is
awesome but like how would you
balance out that effort with the uh main
channel the hdhc productions
so i think a misconception that people
have
is that my lack of uploads on h3h3 was
due to
me focusing my energy to the podcast
when the truth of why i wasn't posting
there had
wasn't an issue of time or commitment or
anything like that
it was really a result of not knowing
what to do there
or not feeling like i was in the right
headspace or
having a lack of motivation or just a
lot of negative bad feelings around
posting there
yeah so for me a lot of people were like
oh
he stopped posting there because the
podcast is more lucrative and he doesn't
care about his fans
or whatever again just kind of people
always want to see the worst in it
and like just assume the worst about
people but the truth of the matter
is and one that i'm addressing now as
best as i can is that
i i am and was depressed
i mean i'm doing much better now i think
and something that i'm working on
but i had a lot of anxiety and a lot of
issues
um that i needed to resolve and a lot of
it was manifesting
itself through how i did my work there
in my primary
you know source of entertainment and so
the podcast was
honestly a way for me to not
disappear it was a way for me to
stay present and to still be working and
to still share
share my life and be with our with the
the people that want that
want to continue to watch us so for me
the podcast was something to do while
i sorted that [ __ ] out and it's been an
incredible
uh resource for me to come here and be
able to share
my thoughts and to not just disappear
right because that's
not something i ever wanted to do and so
i
again i just think it's a misconception
because now we're back to posting videos
there and we're doing both and it's fine
i mean we're busier but it's good i like
being busy and i like feeling productive
and
i really appreciate that i think that
it's i think mental health is something
that's really not addressed a lot and
you know the media and the way that it
is addressed it feels a little bit
underplayed
uh it almost seems as if it's like a
capital brand capitalist brand it's
almost like something you know with the
better health situation everything i'm
not going to get up again but the thing
is is that the way that you're taking it
very head-on and seriously
i i think i can personally commend that
i had my a few hurdles in my life
uh as well uh but i feel as though also
uh when you were talking about you know
kind of
facing an impasse in your uh uploads
because i remember like when ray william
johnson stopped posting
he said something along the lines of he
no longer feels gratitude and doing the
same thing over and over again
so it got me thinking that if you keep
doing the same type of style
the same you know formulaic technique
wouldn't you would you feel like less
intellectually challenged by doing these
videos
well the truth is that i think so much
of
and even maybe what he's saying so much
of the negative feelings that you might
feel is a symptom of
a depressive state and not actually an
expressive
an expression of like your creative art
and that
there's always a way to challenge
yourself and there's always a way
to make it fresh and interesting the
fact is that when you're depressed
you see everything through that lens and
so something i've learned about myself
is that
before i started actually treating my
depression with medicine and therapy
is that you try you scramble and
scramble and try to address
your depression because you don't you
don't like no or you haven't accepted
that you're depressed right
so you're trying in in your mind and in
your life to address
all these different issues and oh that's
why this and that's why that and that's
why this
but the truth is you're never actually
addressing
the root problem you're addressing
symptoms but never the root problem
so when you're depressed and you don't
address that you're always looking for
some answer and you're always to change
and the sad thing about it is that
you're never gonna
fix it until you address the root cause
so for me
now that i'm feeling better making
videos is a wholesome thing and i'm
content doing it where before i was
always looking for something else i was
like
i need to make a show i need to work on
the podcast more i need to uh
get off you i need i need to do all
these other things but those were never
the answer those were just
me looking in vain for something to make
me feel better because i didn't actually
understand
but now that i'm in a better place i can
see that
this is a good place for me and it is a
wholesome place for me
and if you want to express yourself
creatively there's always room
within the formula you've created
to to find a good wholesome productive
happy place it's just a matter of coming
at it through the light lens
i mean it really is a half glass a glass
half full half empty thing and
when you're depressed it's sad sadly
it's always half empty and you really
just can never
see the flip side of it and so the
perspective is very difficult to see in
a
positive light yeah i completely agree
um so i i want to make this a little bit
uh i didn't mean to
drag the mood down that was never my
last good questions i'm happy to talk
about it
you didn't drag it yeah and i think a
lot of people were wondering the same
thing so it's good
actually to talk about it yeah yeah and
uh since you know we're in the spirit of
bringing up things at the end of the
year i thought maybe it would be a
little nice mention to mention some of
your uh best moments in terms of uh
videos on hd productions right i really
loved uh
the honest gold digger it was
it was honestly a really nice highlight
for me because
yo i mean all you did was literally say
you know
the guy's just you know [ __ ]
following the woman uh
the woman was being completely honest
which is exactly true
right and the thing is that repetition
was was the highlight of the whole video
it's it's the same thing over and over
and over again
but it cracks me up every single time
honestly well that's awesome thank you
so much for saying i love that one too
that's cool that was a great one yeah i
liked it because it was it was a little
bit of a twist because
right i kind of resent all the the gold
digger content you see on youtube i
always thought it was just
so ridiculous and um when you finally
get to see inside this
quote unquote gold digger relationship
you realize
that he's the flyer and she's completely
honest about her expectations from the
beginning
and he's the one that misled her right
so it was kind of a funny
uh twist on the whole narrative of the
gold digger
yeah no and uh honestly the thing is is
that um
it's people look at things subject like
specifically you know
she's a gold digger she wants money
that's a negative thing he's a victim
well i mean yeah well she said she's
literally saying that
like it doesn't make it negative it's
negative when you're trying to deceive
someone yeah in order to just
uh achieve an objective she was being
here
she said hey this is what i want can you
give it to me period just give it to me
right there
right i don't even think she ever even
pretended to love him
and he's also in it just for her looks
yeah he wants her fake ass
what is the difference yeah he's a big
fan
that wants to date a pretty girl you
know yeah
you know you know you know it's it's i
mean it's her hustle
and he tried to hustle her and then
first of all the 90-day thing it was
never
meant to work out like it's never about
it's 90 days you've got to watch the
final show
we're watching this show and that show
is there a new season
oh yeah yeah it's turning so
deep what's happening is unimaginable
people are saying it's the darkest
season ever and they're hard to watch
they're
abandoning the show but i'm totally
sucked
those guys i heard that the the guy from
the show got arrested
oh yeah george yeah yeah and i [ __ ] i
called it too because
in the show he's the guy's walking
around with backpacks of weed
you know and then and then a couple
months later
they're like oh we're in legal trouble
and i was like arrested for having tons
of weed and sure enough
he's in prison right now and then fisa
is probably oh she's been like lifting
weights
yeah you've seen her she's all jackson
georgie boy look if you're gonna flex
about the weed business
i mean come on what do you expect to
happen you're gonna like tv i know and
the funny thing is
that he's a drug dealer that's not even
that rich
it's like a kid if you're going to get
drugs at least be richer than that
exactly it's it's it's like there's two
levels of
pathetic right you know there's there's
there's you know the crummy drug dealing
yada yada but then there's
you know pretending to be a successful
one at that yeah to pretend to be a
successful loser you know
it's i don't know it just it just stuck
it for me like that
and uh honestly i just wanted to also
tell you
that you know your commentary style
everything you've done for the past
i have no i i don't have the exact
number of years but you've been doing it
really awesomely
it kind of pushed me to start my own
youtube and everything
so i had a little a few questions before
i you know do my shameless plug-in
you know before i get there i have some
genuine questions for you
um so what since you know we're at the
end of the year
this is also kind of a little bit
retrospective what first motivated you
to make these videos
um well i knew that i wanted to work in
comedy for a long time just because it
was something i was always passionate
about
but i really never i didn't have any
connections i didn't know anyone and
i didn't have any experience making
comedy so
um i think i've mentioned this before
but
but well ela we made a couple of videos
for eli's class and it was really fun
and i and i actually thought i had a
knack for it even though they weren't
good or they were very weird but i
really enjoyed the process so for me it
was kind of started as just a creative
outlet and kind of honing my craft and
figuring out my style
and um it just slowly
turned into having a youtube channel
which is funny because when we started
making youtube videos
i didn't even know youtube being a
youtuber was a thing
yeah i am we just posted it there but we
didn't know
like yeah it it it was just
basically a hobby that somehow slowly
started turning into
something serious um but i guess you
have to have
some kind of continuous motivation i
mean the beginning of youtube
the idea of monetization was just this
abstract you know
far away thought right so you were doing
it based on personal
inhibition personal i guess ambition to
succeed in this industry which is
youtube
well my original idea was that i was
like making a portfolio because i i was
like at best i thought hey i could be a
writer or something
for comedy so i was just thinking that
of youtube as a stepping stone of kind
of just
building a portfolio and honing my craft
and just as a hobby too because i
don't have anything better to do so yeah
i i was thinking of it in the beginning
as a portfolio
something like that and be like hey if i
can make a couple of funny videos
yeah then maybe i can get a job
somewhere
yeah i mean a lot of people from college
humor that's what they did
you know they uh they became writers at
the daily show
stuff like that i completely get you
yeah um
fair enough i guess uh you know i
first of all i i know this is this is a
little bit of a
funny story concerning your name i'm
from saudi arabia and uh we have this
weird thing
with the language basically the letters
and the numbers
uh some numbers because we have
different letters right it's a
arabic so some letters are expressed
with numbers
and when when i was trying to plug your
channel to everyone
i guess in school when i was a kid i
would i would just say h3h3
and the thing is is that when they read
that it says
people everyone sounded like you know
like fat albert and it was it was this
was so weird
either like that alberta getting to
having a stroke some something or the
other
so basically i was plugging it
everywhere and people thought i was
spazzing
and uh so how do you how do you say it
and like uh
and and how what what in arabic how do
you say it
what do you mean the like how were you
saying it i said
h3h3 but i would send them as like text
okay so if you read it so how would they
read it
yeah they would say
[Laughter]
yeah it's it's like bill cosby you know
memorable yeah
but yeah honestly you've been a great
inspiration to me i don't have
anything else to say i just have a few
messages i wanted to say hope you don't
mind
so you're calling right now from saudi
arabia oh yeah i'm calling you guys from
saudi arabia
that's cool that's crazy is there you
guys have a huge fan base here you have
yeah yeah interesting
how interesting right yeah nice i can
tell you every country dude
is there anything weird going on with
like politically like um
because you see i'd rather not get it
you can't talk about that
yeah yeah i can talk to you about like
well i can tell you some good stuff i
can't tell you the bad stuff
uh i could tell you about the uh you
know uh they had the first concert
with mixed like you know the men and
women used to be segregated
and uh they just had the first concert
with black eyed peas david ghetto
they removed the segregation between men
and women which is like a huge thing
interesting have you been have you been
outside of
uh saudi arabia uh yeah totally
i'm actually i study in the uk i'm just
back for christmas spring of course
yeah and uh you know i've been to i've
been to new york i've been to boston and
i've been i've been
i mean for visiting i've been a lot
around but but that you know this
the government is pretty tight there
right about like internet usage and
stuff
i i mean it's it's i guess porn is the
only thing you can't
use
no wonder damn no wonder people i mean
[ __ ] yo that's why people watch your
videos man
yeah that's the next best thing so when
when we see a comment i fap to this it's
not a joke
it's 3am you know you get the urge you
opened you up
yo so let me ask you this are people in
saudi arabia getting all
are do they jerk off to like this like
you know or the video we made like the
egg sandwich video
is that like good dude that's the top
search dude
that's the good [ __ ] in saudi arabia is
that what people beat off yeah
3 a.m education but you probably used to
h3 you probably use a vpn right if
you're trying to find some good [ __ ]
i i don't talk about that
[Music]
i mean look let's be real i mean in
terms of vpn usage it's it's not even
like hidden like people use vpn
regularly because
the thing is that it used to be the case
that like stuff like whatsapp call is
banned
it's not that you can't call people it
was only banned
because the the main conglomerate uh
didn't want competition
they just wanted people the phone it
wasn't even like a censorship type of
deal
they just didn't want any company but
then they decided
like let's just have uh what's it called
like a
comp competitive market so you know just
they
unbanned it and uh yeah what's up calls
back that's a huge stride after the
women driving thing
it's nice i use whatsapp all the time to
call
israel i'm just imagining not having
porn i mean
what a [ __ ] nightmare
i would be i would definitely be on
youtube like there's some weird
pornographic videos on youtube that we
always make fun of i would be there
naked yoga i just see i just need to see
a little bit of side boob and i'm coming
in my pants
i have a little more sympathy for him
bro you got you got you got what's
filthy frank and and max mofo and
idubbbz doing videos together and you
want us to look for the the side food
that's enough
don't they don't overlap i need both
you need both what if we got a filthy
frank's side
would that be good come on i'm just into
my pants you have to thought of it
so what's your use do you want to plug
your
channel yeah you were just going to do
it i think
uh okay so first of all my friend really
insisted that i say this message um so
sophia gagliano supports and loves you
and shredder
really wanted me to say that god bless
you sophia
and and then there's the uh
base my channel is called fifths
yeah and the thing is and here's the
thing before you guys close the call
because i've been talking too much i
know
um basically the thing is i hope i
posted
one fortnight critic critical analysis
which sounds very
juvenile but i mean i wanted to upload
another video but i didn't get the
chance
quite uh but it's coming up in a few
days whatever the hell if that means
anything
but yeah you guys should follow it and
uh yeah
that's my hustle i hope you guys have a
good stream i hope thank you
guys thank you yeah we had we did have a
great stream and i
actually very appreciate you donating
and calling in
actually interesting to talk to somebody
from saudi arabia to a fan from there
that's very cool
dude we should keep in touch we should
keep in touch because yeah
i like that that fresh perspective out
there although i don't know how much you
can talk about but it's very fascinating
to connect with somebody on that side of
the world
well thank you for the thoughtful
questions thank you for the donation
thank you for watching man
we appreciate you dude and best of luck
with everything you're doing
mm-hmm with you
[Music]
what a treat cool yeah crazy no porn
no wonder those [ __ ] guys over there
are so like
well maybe you should try it ethan
but you want me to let go i'm just
[Laughter]
i'm just saying just saying no fap
there's a thing no fap
i've gotten a lot of emails since we
talked about it yeah that was a popular
discussion encouraging it so and then uh
before i forget there was one other
person not a call but just somebody that
uh
had donated a bunch and we possibly i i
think we actually did do the shout out
but he emailed
me and he he missed it so shout out to
motivation app
uh he donated uh i think 350 bucks
on the stream and uh
sorry we missed you sorry we missed you
and
uh just wanted to to just give you some
acknowledgement uh
that uh you did a good thing and so
thanks a lot man
thank you well guys
it's 2018 episode 100
we've done it all we've seen it all
we've been through the strikes the
gutters
all together what a touching beautiful
thing ela's pregnant
um ian's got real yeezys
golly what a year it's all it's all
happened
we've done it all yeah and i can't
believe people
watched it all i know they've stuck
around by golly you papa blessed little
little fupa troopers i love you guys man
thanks for sticking around
i i hope that the show i i am i'm
committed
i love this i'm committed to making it
better to becoming a better interviewer
a better host
putting together a better show it's been
great it's been a real
experience for us and next year 2019
we've got a lot of plans a lot of
ambition
very excited to get back into it
i'm going to take a month to recharge
we're going to be making a lot of
h3h3 videos we're going to be focusing
on that so
tune in there i'm excited just to kind
of focus on that for a little bit which
is something
we haven't done in a very long time yeah
we weren't excited about it for a long
time exactly and
and i am i'm feeling i'm feeling
motivated to make videos there again for
the first time
um when we're back the first episode
back
is michael stevens vsauce on the
correct me if i'm wrong dan the 21st or
25th of january
yeah um he's got a new uh
season of minefield i'm sure we're gonna
have a ton of stuff to talk about
and the episode after that i want to get
a furry in here in costume
or two or two yeah and i've been seeing
all your emails
uh furry community uh dan's gonna vet
you guys yeah i'm gonna i'm gonna read
through them all
we've been pretty buried with the
charity stream but yeah you know
we see you and uh we're gonna work on uh
engaging
the furry community and i wanna thank
the community and everyone involved who
rallied
to raise so much money for people who
so desperately need it i'm so proud of
you guys
proud of the community i just and i'm
just so thankful and
and i have so much gratitude um
to our fans who stuck around they're
thick and thin
you know i've had a rough year i've dead
and i've done and said
a lot of stupid [ __ ] it's you know
some and i got a lot of [ __ ] for it and
you know it's tested me
more than i've ever been tested in my
life and um
as kendrick lamar said you know when
[ __ ] hits the fan are you still a man
you know and um some and you guys
are still man a lot of people stuck
around and [ __ ] with us even at the
worst of times so
what more can you ask for than that
right mm-hmm
so i happy holidays yeah everyone of
course happy holidays
have a merry merry christmas whatever
you're doing out there
i am not uh i do not have a war on
christmas i'll say it merry christmas i
love
christmas yeah happy hanukkah and every
goddamn every quan
does anyone celebrate kwanzaa i don't
they always say happy kwanzaa but i've
never known anyone to celebrate kwanzaa
but i'm not discriminated
i'm just saying i don't know if they
just throw that in there
but happy kwanzaa you know everybody
happy whatever
new years god damn damn it uh so we are
gonna be
[Music]
we're gonna be going in there man h3
time baby
i'm excited and i and i i don't i don't
know how to end this because i am so
just so sincerely
grateful and it's been a wild year it's
been a
wild year the longest year
it's been the longest year ever
so fast too it's the longest year ever
for me for me pure length
i've heard i've heard a lot of people
say that i'm
i feel both i feel like it's well
imagine it's long but it's also
short like it's already december it's
over let me 2019
yeah but let me put it in let me put it
in context for you
let me see what were we doing around the
beginning of the year let me tell you
what episode we were doing to kind of
put it in context
um first one first one was
uh jack and eric the first two weeks of
this year we
that was we went to israel together
remember that does seem like it
10 years ago yeah oh and while you were
in israel the logan paul incident
happened
right right and that was the first h3h3
video back no
so and it's weird some things feel short
and some
things
you know it's been great
so i thank everybody and i'll see you in
a month
yeah but i will see you earlier on h3
and
what can you say man 2019.
what can you say other than this
love you guys love you guys and uh
have a great holiday and yeah go
celebrate pop a blast
take some time off just enjoy enjoy man
all right we'll be seeing you guys real
soon thanks for watching
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you